pay offs getting into its which today I
will just remind members that there is
an act on Suffolk Canada councils
highways website where you can go on and
tell them about the around situations
and your coming so I suggest you all do
that
it might help anyway and we're still
expecting one or two people to a row
you've heard down on our list of wishing
to speak or what have you so they've got
time to still get here but we'll make a
start
the first item Thank You chair
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room down the corridor cold water is
available outside in the breakout area
and if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room for
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the Ipswich Town Football Club
training pitch and please remain there
until you are told it is safe to return
also please ask these which are all
mobile phones will turn them to silent
as there is donation to the Chairman's
charity if not oh that's a new little
bit add a dog I forgot mom's days I can
turn it off right the council members of
the public and press may record filmed
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded baby district canceled
our first record in this meeting any
member of the public who attends of
meetin and objects terbium films should
have a file use the committee Clark as
far as I'm aware no one has indicated
that they will be filming or that they
do not want to be filmed is that still
the case okay thank you in accordance
with the council's plan on charter
members of the
they are not permitted to communicate
whether verbally or in writing with
members of the committee during the
course of the meeting including any
adjournments if a member of the
committee is approached by a member of
the public then they must draw it and
really tomorr attention and also the
attention of the legal affairs the
present if a member of the public
attempt to communicate with a member of
the committee then they may be asked to
leave the meeting finally can members
and officers and also public speakers
ensure that you press the microphone for
speaking and turn it off when you're
finished and try and keep as close as
possible to it so that we can all hear
you do know how late is in front of it
because it blocks it as well thank you
[Applause]
substitutes and apologies cancel our
daters accounts a Davis Fort Lee Parker
thank you very much yep okay take care
we have one other apology this morning
of councillor Norman thank you and with
no substitute
Alton number two decorations of interest
canceler Buzzbee that was a good guess
yes I declare an interest in 6b as
cabinet member for assets and
investments which includes Borland gate
and Hamilton Road
I do have views on what should be
happening there and they may or may not
coincide with what's going on here so
I'll actually step out during this thank
you'll note that in your leads to meet
and at that point of men return for the
other one
thank you no other declarations of
interest no item for to confirm the
minutes held on the fifth on the night
of October you've all had seen the
copies of this can I sign them as a true
record I'm still pencil heirs seconded
by Councillor Busby all those in favor
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
right deliver the petitions nun received
yeah thank you
site inspections you pull them any site
inspections yes yeah would you like to
do that now then please um a site visit
has been requested by councillor Parker
unfortunately he's not here today
he has sent an email to explain his
reasons why he goes a site visit is
necessary
he said that given that committee has
new members I think it's important that
they have the opportunity to visit the
site in order to gain visual context
orbit in relation to the existing street
scene in particular he would be keen for
members to view the proposed site the
location in context to existing
dwellings and position within the
village and the proposed access the
proposal has generated significant
interest locally and I think it
pertinent an appropriate that members
should view the application site for
themselves prior to the application
coming before committing Thank You
counselor Hinton Thank You mr. chairman
just a good one where are we talking
about
okay site it is in a Centon
it sits behind the farm shop it's an
outline planning provision the 1920s
with access to be considered this is the
site location it's currently used as a
caravan site the site is located within
a special landscape area and to the east
of the site is the flood zone which is
shown on the map the main street of
Essington is to the west of the site and
you can see the access point marked out
in that orange color there the site is
in pink as councillor Parker has said
there has been several applications
around the site we have three
applications in total which has
generated 23 dwellings all three have
actually been granted to the north of
the site which is just at the top there
where it says existing site plan 8
houses have been given permission then
to the south of the site another 8 and
then in the middle sanction there is oh
there we go
sorry so 8 up the top here 8 down the
bottom here and 7 here this is the site
area to be considered this is just a
visual of what it may look like with the
19 dwellings on the site and that is it
thank you
well memories you've seen the
photographs do you think that's
sufficient or do wish to go on a site
inspection
I haven't seen any photographs well
that's the secret plans yeah yeah we
haven't seen these photographs which
might have you seen the plans that are
really fancy on the ground yeah I I
think that perhaps we should go along
and see this somebody's second it yep
councillor Busby any other comments
no all those in favor of site inspection
please show anyone against why I create
thank you that's carried we'll have a
site inspection that will be next
Wednesday a bit later a bit later a
closer to the committee date we don't
actually have a committee dates yeah
because of the election right normally
we don't freakin quite a semi but yeah
because of the election so that's gonna
be December then isn't it really
so we'll inform you when the date is
sorted okay
it certainly won't be next Wednesday
thank you members is there any site
inspections that you wish to call
councillor Busby the chair I have
mentioned there's a couple in copped off
but I'd like the planning committee go
and have a look at but they're not ready
yes right well I think they can note it
and then hopefully bring up forward one
of them one of them is the alterations
to the Cameo Hotel fully cocked up or
them basic ways to put it which until
these days which is quite a significant
developments and quite controversial in
the area and the other one is the other
side of the road it's an ancient what's
an old barn is probably one of the
oldest buildings in the area and how
that's going to be converted and brought
into use with the existing house
Thank You Leah well officers note that
and then that come back to us in two
parts cancer Jemison yeah I'd like to
ask for slightly deeper development
posed in urban in Kersey I believe the
committee previous committee has been
out to look at this on the earlier
occasion obviously there's a change of
committee now it's quite controversial
it's
development situated behind great -
stylistic buildings and it's a great to
type hub and it's quite a lot of
Correspondence in the British do you
know when this is likely to come to us
I'm not sure I suggest you have a work
the offices afterwards find out when
it's come and if it's imminent then yes
we can deal with it quickly and if it if
it's coming in the new year or later
then we can make sure that we pick it up
near at the time okay do you have a
residence number for it not at home no
we'll check it out
okay pair of us think he'll remembers no
other site inspections of course so
we'll move on to item number six and
we're guarantee we're going to take item
C 6 C which is on page 51 and that's 40
George Street Hadley forest
[Applause]
the reason we bring that forward we've
got all of them people present that have
said they were going to be here so we're
going to deal with that one first so if
anyone else is stuck in traffic they've
got the opportunity to get here for the
apples to write to you Thank You chair
morning members and public so this
application relates to direction of one
dwelling a new virtual access in Hadley
14 George Street so the key issues here
with this application is the potential
harm to the listed building and what
public benefits outweigh this harm if
any at all to what extent the proposed
development actually sits harmoniously
within the landscape and the existing
townscape particularly in regards to the
conservation area and see what extent to
the Hadley swimming pool which is
adjacent to the site is likely to cause
potential residential community issues
to any future occupiers as well as the
design or sea of the proposed welling so
here you can see the site you've got 14
42 George Street to the north and Hadley
Leisure Centre C is to the south along
with a car park and another car park
further east you've got sort of open
space along to the west which also runs
behind the Leisure Centre as you can see
here there's several listed buildings
both agreed to include to star within
the vicinity and it's right in the heart
or we'll see the constellation area
so this puts it into you'll see its
aerial view you can see the the greenery
and the landscape and part planned which
predominately surrounds one listed
building but also the swimming pool so
there was a previous application last
year which was very similar to this one
however it was for the erection of one
and a half story dwelling it was refused
as an officer delegated decision and it
was refused based on the harm caused to
the heritage asset to the north
residential amenity for future occupiers
and it was considered TV backlund
development so this is the previous
refusal block plan so you can see
roughly where it's going to sort of the
northeast is a garage and to vary north
of the site is or c40 George Street this
is basically an overlay so this is a
current proposal situated and then on
top VLA demonstrates the previous
refused application so here you can see
that although they proposing
single-story the footprint has increased
over so slightly and these are the
proposed elevations so you've got single
single storey bungalow
I'll see brickwork and weather boarding
I say so he's a missus existing floor
fan it was quite small two beds bungalow
this was a previous one that was refused
so this is the one and a half story and
the dotted line just shows the change in
height so this is the main difference
between the previous refusal is the fact
that we've reduced the height fairly
significantly
this is then 40 and 42 George Street it
was listed in 1950 it's also 17th
century history timber framed and
plastered building with a fast roof it's
quite prominent in the area it's quite
prominent in the street scene along with
40 along George Street particularly as
you've got the open space to the south
with it it's also I've seen the
conservation area so this image is from
the cuddly simple so you can see the
hedgerow which borders the existing
dwelling and the dotted line
demonstrates approximately where the
roof line would be for this proposed
dwelling so from village centre and the
wider Green Park area it would be quite
dominant in comparison to listed
building and in fact from this point of
view it would pretty much end up
blocking your view and appreciation of
the listed building our heritage team
have said that it causes a low to
moderate level of less than substantial
harm both to your CV listed building and
the conservation area so the red area
des marks where the entrance would be
and as you can see at the moment I'll
see the the curtilage is mature header
area trees and there's some green open
space and foot part
so in terms of harm the MPPs says of see
any harm to a list building must be
considered and great weight attributed
it to it unless there are see public
benefits that outweigh that harm so just
on expiration so if there's no harm to
either the listed building itself or see
the setting then you know that any
application is acceptable less than the
substantial harm you can have an
editable you can have low moderate high
and then I'll see you've got substantial
harm which is an PPF paragraph 195 this
proposal is considered to cause between
low and moderate level of lessen
substantial harm and the public benefits
one dwelling now a Birkin at present
demonstrate a five-year housing land
supply
I appreciate there is a need for
potentially single-story bungalows and
within Hadley however the one dwelling
is not considered to outweigh the harm
caused to not only the list the building
in its immediate setting but also the
wider setting as well as the
conservation area and as such the
application should ship F will be
refused in line with four paragraphs
hundred ninety three 296 of the NPP F
and here's a historic map where you can
see this is I'll see before where letter
sent it was built you can see that to
the north of George Street all the other
properties are quite dense they're all
fronting the highway and they're quite
tight whereas George streets is
basically in the middle of the open area
and the swimming pool is also impinged
on that setting off door Street slightly
however it still set far back and it's
not considered to be within its
immediate setting whereas this proposed
dwelling would obviously be in the
garden curtilage
therefore the immediate setting of the
great II listed building so there is
obviously an existing bungalow and the
white building you can see to the writer
that is 40 42 George Street so there has
been some development in close proximity
however that was it's been there for
quite a while and because of its
orientation and the fact that it does
sit on its own plot further to the right
it's not considered to have as much of
an impact as this proposal in terms of
residential immunity there's concern
that also its buyer beware that future
occupiers will be potentially disturbed
by members of public and people visiting
the swimming pool I was swimming pool is
recently had permission which I believe
is now under way for an extension
so in could potentially have more
visitors and is a car park directed to a
south of the site and one slightly
favored way to the but there's a large
amount of will see traffic movement as
you see the cars you know go to the car
park either way and so on either drop
off the potentially swimming classes or
see to actually attend the leisure
center themselves and here as well seen
all the noise would technically come
from in terms of the back land
development which is another reason for
refusal you can see that there's an
outbuilding within the existing bungalow
curtilage but within 1442 George Street
there are no outbuildings there are no
other buildings within gardens and it's
it's read as sort of one hole one hole
almost one whole garden as well as a
wider Park area to the north and south
there's a lot of greenery not that many
reforms with the exception of
hardly swimming pool that's just putting
it into a wider context for you in terms
of you know the buildings and the number
of buildings within that area I miss one
it mister shows or see the the townscape
and the greenery to emphasize that if
you put another dwelling or see in this
location but significantly altering the
the existing character of the area which
is predominately open space and then
resetting into the listed building so
for the reasons explained that
particularly the low to moderate level
of harm this application should be
refused because it's not enough benefit
from one housing to outweigh that harm
there's also concern in terms of
residential amenity for future occupiers
although of see it is buyer beware if
you're going to potentially buy the
house you would would be aware of it
Thank You Catherine right so point of
order yeah and apologies chair but just
looking at this I think it's prudent
that I mentioned her I'm sure the
solicitor can help me that I am the
cabinet member of communities which part
of the Hadley Leisure Centre is his
parts of that and obviously the ongoing
works I've had a part to play in there I
know I'll have no adverse effect
whatsoever I thought it was ported to
mention him very well you said we'd like
to comment the chair I'm quite happy
that that's not an interested would
should disqualify council Davis he's
he's wise to mention it for that sort no
sir thank you will note that
ten counsel gavin Tolbert i'd like to
come forward so here three minutes in
which to address the committee that
should remain seated or standing at the
part there are woods and I'll save this
any questions from members to you thank
you hello and thanks for having me and
we we've come along to this meeting
having discussed at our town council
meeting and we which is where we had no
issue with approving it and the
reasonable come along was because the
recommendation for a refusal on it and
it's specifically around the Heritage
bit that is our focus understand there
may be other issues and that that you
may want to discuss and that are what
I'm going to say it's purely focused on
the Heritage because we think that
there's a kind of inconsistency in the
way that has been approached to some
degree compared to other development in
that area when we were discussing it at
the town council meeting heritage with
his obviously a key consideration we had
with it being in a conservation area and
there's a number of us who have actually
over beers had a kind of keen interest
in that particular area with various
things have been going on so we have
good knowledge of the area we also were
quite keen to see what the Hadley
Society and sort of view of it was as
they're very knowledgeable on the local
heritage of the area we know that they
didn't have any real Jepsen's to it's
just suggesting there should be three
conditions that are placed on the
application if it's approved and and
that there's they seem to feel happy
that from the previous refusal that some
of the key issues for refusal that has
she been dealt with and I think what was
our concern was the heritage team with
view on it because it feels like it is
in consist
and with some other development in that
area in particular the swimming pool and
East house where those developments have
actually been given a rating of low harm
whereas this is actually country to what
nothing I just heard said where it's
given low to moderate in the report at
least he actually says that it's got a
medium level of less than substantial
harm which seems inconsistent with the
previous applications for the swimming
pool and east house and their music and
and just kind of to suggest that a
single for bung that I wish we're from
the picture we were only really going to
see a bit of roof it appears would have
a big impact on the heritage of the area
when you've got a massive swimming pool
there for example which clearly has a
public benefit but you know I was
struggling to see how that makes a
medium level of harm when other stuff in
the area which is far bigger has a low
level of harm
and we kind of felt that the report
seems to suggest it's going to be a lot
more visible and actually appears to be
it certainly doesn't look to be visible
from the time as far as how he was now
up so he just remained seated there are
since any questions to you members
before I go any further we do have the
heritage officer present dr. dark and he
will speak at some point during this but
at the mobis taking notes so they can
comment later members any questions have
you got yes counselor Davis yeah you
make a very good point about the
heritage report and in the report it
does indeed say medium and but also says
that the MPP F passed away against the
level of harm for the benefit what
benefit do you think this development
would bring to Hadley
okay I mean clearly it's obviously
different with us women policy that has
public benefit I think the key benefit
here is though that Hadley does need
houses that are of a one level house for
like older people to be able to downsize
into which i think is what the applicant
actually essentially looking to do here
and you know we've we've got another
development there but it's just not
enough of those sort of houses so I
think there is a public benefit and of
secant Grady in the same way as a
swimming pool that has a benefit to a
lot of people and that there is a type
of housing that is needed in the area
thank you any other questions
consider Busbee to wet palm and compare
it to the swing pool but don't you think
that a modern building in the garden of
a 17th century listed building is it's a
bit different it's like comparing apples
and pears oh yeah I mean absolutely you
know you are talking about different
things I think it was really just to
point out that when you can it's just
that inconsistency it doesn't look like
make that house bearing in mind you know
what you're saying there is very
different to swimming pool but it
doesn't look like it's being treated
slightly more harshly in a way than a
swimming pool which yes has a bigger
public benefit but it is a massive thing
in a open space and you know when we
look at the East house development as
well we're sort of see the original plan
for that was to actually build onto the
park area as well and again that has a
fairly big impact and now I'm not saying
that there's necessary this should be a
low level of impact and they've got it
wrong from that point of view but maybe
that the other ones should be a higher
impact potentially I am I'm not the
expert there and just pointing out there
does seem to be an inconsistency there
in the way that this one's been treated
whether that's they don't kill no our
highest into the matter yeah thank you
any other questions No thank you very
much
is there anything you wish to comment
from that no yes I'll come back I'll
come back to talk to that a little bit
later we don't have an objector we do
have and she's in the wrong box right we
have an objector Sheila Lara
you have three minutes of wish to
address the committee and if you remain
that end of service any questions for
you when you're ready just press the
button and then you can carry on thank
you well thank you for the opportunity
of speaking to you about this
application
I live at 42 George Street in the other
half of the semi-detached cottage a
number 40 my garden backs onto the site
of the proposed building last September
objected to the previous application in
this site as did many of my neighbors
and the permission was refused this
application is on the same site as
before and the only changes is being
it's a bungalow not a house I share the
support of the concerns of health
heritage office about the adverse
effects on the character of my property
and next door by building her in the
garden directly behind my back garden
wall I am very concerned about the
safety of children attending assault
center since the access to the bungalow
is in the service road and the cars
turning and the health of the site would
be the road safe hadith hazard coaches
often drop off in this area the personal
circumstances and application is not
reveled as the burglar will be a
permanent fixture long after it is not
needed but mrs. Quinlan I wholeheartedly
agree with mrs. with the report of
Katherine health and her conclusions and
asked that they be backed by the
committee and permission is refused as
it was before there is a blood bank
vehicle once a year and people come in
and give blood and the lorries 44 4
o'clock and this would be right behind
the new building in front of the new
building the access to the new property
that Narvik Quinlan exactly the position
is in exactly the same place because it
was before it has not been challenged
mid Fraser has agreed to speak on behalf
of mr. Marino and I can
I think okay I can imagine that can you
imagine him but the chaos idiot is led
through persevere course go in and out
of behind the access point such as
digger cement mix mixes lorries dropping
theater dropping me a Kaffir material
off but the build this is going to be as
long as it takes and could be months new
buildings in historic town is a in the
back garden swimming pool coaches and a
health side coaches visiting mothers and
children that use the park walking to
school in Hadley and we cannot be losing
bit by bit
parking the emergency services will not
have the place to park if you allow this
access road to be used by mrs. Quinlan
this laser Center has not got any other
loading bay is this a conservative
Conservation Area and properties are
bright to elicited this proposal was
turned down last year so we hope to be
flipped out again thank you
members have you got any questions and
just one you did say that members of the
public walk and Bowie would be affected
but that's a private garden so they
can't go in there now is that correct
coming out with a car many visitors will
be using that a deterrence as well and
she would only way she can come out of
that entrance he's not coming out but no
major event you've made that night for
you yes thank you
members any other questions no thank you
very much thank you is there anything
you wish
right we don't have a supporter so we
would then go to the applicants agent
which is mr. Ben Alvin I think we know
the procedures I won't repeat it we have
three minutes then kill more in chair
morning members and thanks again for the
opportunity to address you as you've
heard this application is a resubmission
of a previously refused scheme where the
applicant has scaled down the scheme to
a single storey property and as you saw
from the plans it's a significant
reduction in height those that was done
in response to the previous concerns the
Heritage drop zone and since that
previous application as you've heard we
now have no objection from the Town
Council or from the heavy Society who
had both previously ejected the proposal
also has a clean bill of health from the
highway authority you'll consult an
ecologist and the land contamination
officer there are a number of letters to
support for the proposal mean this is an
application that now has little in the
way of objection and much in the way of
support locally indeed we understand
that some representatives are here today
to speak in support of proposal in
particular the Town Council it is clear
that one of the main issues of the
Harwich impacts and we consider that
these impacts have been overplayed and
that some context is needed in respect
of how the proposal would actually
impact the property was listed in 1950
it was built in not in 1663 the
application site was not brought into
the ownership of number 40 until the
applicant and her husband bought it in
the 1960s so at the time when the
building was listed this land did not
belong to this two building and also for
the first 300 years of his existence
this land did not belong to Lister
building it was in separate ownership
and separate use historical mapping
shows at the time the property was
listed as you've seen the edge' Center
did not exist nor did stone house wrote
all the adjacent carpark all the
bungalow known is 42 a George Street
which sits behind the frontage of 42 or
the modern garage building which I'm
disappointed you haven't seen in
photographs this morning which sits
behind that bungalow and adjacent to our
site the Heritage Officer identifies the
views of number 40 from the road itself
as being important to his significance
but does not recognize the new bungalow
would not be
able to be seen from the road it would
not be possible to see the new dwelling
and the list of building in the same
context from George Street and thereby
the visual appreciation in respect to
the impact in the conservation area and
saying a list the building have been
overplayed the proposal would retain the
original garden area to the list of
property identifying the proposal as
tandem development is factually
incorrect it is not accessed past the
existing house as its own road frontage
to the ledger center side the extension
to the leisure center is vastly more
prominent in this modest bungalow would
be a leisure center itself has more of
an impact on the heritage asset relative
to all this proposal would have in terms
of the impact resulting from the leisure
center and the suggested refusal is
unfounded I was commissioned by baby
district council to prepare the
statement support with the planning
application for the leisure center
extension which is currently being built
I was advised by the council to make
clear the extension will bring about
improvements to the noise attenuation of
that building and that was the message
that was given to the public and it
would improve the impact on existing
properties yet it now appears the legend
whose been used as a reason to refuse
this application due to noise concerns
this is particularly surprising given
that no objections have been received
from the councilors Environmental
Protection Team who were wholly
supportive of the words proposed the
ledger so the land is already garden and
the new dwelling would be more insulated
than the existing buildings which have
little in the way of installation
members the applicant has addressed the
council's previous concerns such this is
now supported by many who previously
objected is delivering a bungalow I
would have taken your tiny thought thank
you I'll serve him any questions could
you just for my benefit you said the
land the land that you're proposing to
put the development on originally in the
60s did not belong or was part of the
heritage site which plants that is that
correct whoever it was bought by the
applicant in the 1960s and never
previously belonged to the site so that
was never included when they thank you
and the garish side I'll take that up
with the officers sure
right members have you got any questions
cleanse Silla Buzzbee it's nice to see
better gamer see more of you now than
when you work do you talk about that
bland behind where the proposed
development is what was it before it was
taken into as thank you for it film part
of their previous popular deed the
historic map actually the Catherine show
chose it quite clearly it's forming part
of that wider past the land where the
ledger sent has now been constructed on
yeah so it's never been designed as
allocated as a use for housing it was
always a green area absolutely it's been
in close it's enclosed by walling as
part of the garden to number-14 now but
that's only a relatively modern
development since it was born yeah
cancel a barrack follow fire codes of
Davis you mentioned the garage that you
said it's a shame we haven't seen a
picture of that or anything detailing
that um can you just confirm who owns
this garage and are you suggesting that
that is a harmful to the heritage asset
no think would I think the view is you
see there to the left of that bungalow
is a modern garage that it seems
regardless that's been built into the
bungalow
I was delaford can you dim the lights so
we can see it sorry to interrupt you
carry on actually that that previous
image was helpful the one second to that
we'll get that image back up because the
the member need us to see where that was
there is yep the the the building that's
pointed there the image that you had of
the bungalow to the side that that
garage is not shown there's a modern
garage has been built in the garden of
that so you've got a number 42 a behind
number 14 42 and behind that is that
garage on the corner which sits adjacent
to our sides
Bera can you use a moment alright is
that the best view controllers all that
what you say what a moment ago which to
the side to you the side view shows the
bungalow but the the garages further to
be welcome to erase it to the west but
it's only shown on there before and how
old is the garage and I'm not sure on
that one
Clint sorry mr. Alvin dunno how old the
garages that split built
I don't chairman not its modern misleads
the last three years yet pencil the day
to see you next time yeah that thanks
I've been you you've adequately given
explanations why you think it's wrong to
refuse on on the three on two of the
three reasons number two and number
three but how would you argue against
the the officers recommendation the
first one where it says it would be a
Crampton can try form of development and
it's contrary to a number of policies I
think again if week if you could show
that aerial image that had the garage on
please if that's possible you might be
twenty
I think I think as you can see members
you've got a the historic building to
the right hand side of the white square
you've got a modern more modern bungalow
just to the south of the white square
with them with a modern garage to the
west of that and our plot is the area to
the north of that garage it's in essence
a squaring off from the development it's
it's already a sort of a compact little
pub area development and that separate
piece of land is actually enclosed by
walls it is in an edging it's a walled
garden in essence along the back
separate from the original courage of
the property so from our point of view
we don't consider it particularly
cramped and and the office also
mentioned there are no other buildings
on the site that's not correct there's
actually a garage and stable building
associated with number 40 which you can
just make out and solve half way along
the northern boundary of the the white
square there and that information wasn't
actually correct
there are outbuildings I think members
it's important that we're aware that
there are buildings there I think it's
been outlined and we perhaps should
heads and clearer photographs showing
those because I looked at it the other
night when I went to the leisure center
and I thought there was more dwellings
around it but anyway any other questions
members penciler Busby
he would agree that two wrongs don't
make a right the wrong the initial wrong
was building that other bungalow in the
garage that detracts from the building
because we've done that doesn't mean
that we should go ahead and accessor
bait the situation sure I didn't say the
other one was wrong I'm just pointing
out that there is development in the
curtilage that building already and I
don't think this therefore gives rise to
harm and the decision previously taken
was probably that it wasn't harmful to
the listed building otherwise it
wouldn't be there and two wrongs don't
make a right
absolutely agree but I don't think this
is wrong I will leave you to work that
out so I canceled the Busbee any other
questions no thank you very much thank
you is there anything you wish to
comment what you've just heard I think
with the cramped and contrived form of
development if you can get a slice by
that where you look at the proposed
dwelling within the proposed curtilage
it does end up sitting on most of what's
available and therefore the amenity
space was a bungalow would be only two
beds and would be small in size you
wouldn't expect a large amount of garden
curtilage former property it would eat
up most of it particularly when you have
a car parking as well on the site and it
would be very limited which is how we
reach the conclusion it it created a
more cramped and contrived appearance I
think in terms of see the Heritage it's
probably best that Jeff comes along and
Leslie explains the setting and why
badly swimming pool is also a different
situation to this provides dwelling
thank you yes I'll go to talk about the
mix but I think it is also worth noting
the people who don't size and they want
bungalows and small bungalows don't
necessarily want large Gardens so you
know balances ourself up it can work out
either way and doctored up would you
like to comment on what you've heard
Thank You chair
and I think we look at this we look at
the overview of the the facts we had
before us the building is listed
government listed it to protect earth
what's gone before has gone before
whether it's got consent weather's given
a consent at appeal where the Heritage
were involved or not not relevant to
this case our buildings in the grounds
of the building I don't know what age
they are they may have been there when
it was listed they may have planning
permission to be erected afterwards I
don't know nevertheless this is a
bungalow in the grounds of a wrote a
list of building Catherine showed you
the old OS map I think the the first
edition 1880s and on the northeast side
of George Street all the houses are very
very close together they're touching
obviously they're terraces and there are
in fills and they're very attractive but
they are of a lower status than this
17th century timber frame and the lower
status is illustrative or is it
illustrated by the size of the gardens
as much as the extent of the the
frontage they are smaller buildings some
of them are actually or post the motion
low and they want an off story and one
story in that room on this side of the
road on the south and east side number
40 is a large earlier timber frame very
significant building and also it's
interesting to note the size of their
garden in respect of the the size of the
building is a much bigger garden
relating to a much bigger house because
it's a much higher status now a lot of
the buildings opposite are very
attractive but aren't listed by the by
the government except the ones in the
north north and east a lot of those
buildings are non designated assets but
they have small gardens number 14 42 has
a very big garden and it's interesting
on several issues the agent says the
building the site where the house is
being built was never in the ownership
of the house apparently built in 1663 i
wasn't there in the 17th century
i don't know who owned it but it's quite
diagnostic for me looking at the size of
the land
that surrounds it it's all open land
it's not being built on me that tells me
that through the history I mean I wasn't
there but through history and my
experience open land like that around a
building suggests that they owned that
land and they kept it for their own
orchards their own animals their own
agriculture it turns out now it's a park
they may have given me I don't know
nevertheless it's not been developed on
so it stands alone it's a very
significant building I hear what the
agent says about the bungalow built in
perhaps the 60s the building was listed
1950 a bungalow came along the 1960s
heritage and and the legislation and the
guidance have all tightened up
dramatically since the 60s obviously
we're now in the 21st century we don't
let things go though that heritage think
a harmful will objective or will say the
armful the issue the swimming pool is
obviously a different issue the town
council said oh well they've got a they
designate a low level farm to it well we
take each on its merits we have no
interest other than protection of the
environment the conservation area in
this case and the setting listed
buildings so 40 the development of a
house a bungalow in a back garden of a
significant listed building is seriously
harmful now anything if I could just
take you through a couple of quick
things
Kathryn raised the issues about
paragraphs chapter 16 of the NPP F
national Plains which the framework I
would just like to reiterate chapter one
paragraph one no force is any harm to or
loss of significance of a do the nature
NASA any harm requires clear and
convincing justification well I'm
our own policy CNO six which we rely on
quite a bit it's very useful policy it
says in proposals that involve new
development within a setting of listed
buildings or within the curtilage or
setting must be of an appropriate scale
form citing and detailed design to
harmonize with the existing building and
its setting now as I say that building
is a major 17th century building perhaps
arguably the most significant house in
George Strait house individual house
even though it's now - it says it must
retain a curtilage and/or setting which
is appropriate to the list of building
and the relationship with its
surroundings by sticking a house in the
back garden of a grade-two house we are
not retaining an appropriate setting or
curtilage and then finally
the setting parity chasis guidance will
historic England second edition lists a
checklist of 27 points which are
potential attributes of a development
which will affect the setting or could
affect the setting of of a building and
the first one of those 27 is proximity
to the asset this is that far away
almost so off that list of 27 potential
attributes proximity is the one historic
England put at the top of that list and
so for all these reasons the heritage
team found a low to moderate level of
harm lessen substantial which is as I've
said previously 95% of all harm to
listed buildings in character of
conservation area is less the
substantial substantial harm is only
retained for so the demolition of a
listed building or something of that
that sort of magnitude everything else
is on a spectrum of lessen substantial
as Catherine's Illustrated so for those
reasons heritage team do not support the
scheme thank you
I'm just a little confused because you
said that the it was built in the garden
or the the new dwelling would be built
nearest to the heritage building but you
also said that there was a new carriage
nearby sure listener of a new garage
that's built in the other garden yeah I
mean I'm not aware olfi the age of that
garage it is quite new that's like over
there there's a Gary's that's nearer to
it that was the point oh yeah but my
concern is how closely is to the list of
building can your help on that because
thank you chair we don't have the
planning history of the garage in front
of us it's possible that it's in the
garden of a non listed building and it
was PD we don't know I don't think we
should hang our hopes on that being a
bellwether for the proposal here today
well we've been not hanging our hopes on
it but that is there is a garage there
so you just need to be aware of that
right remembers we've still got one more
public speaker and that is the local
ward member councillor Mike Fraser
councillor Katherine Grandin I've even
heard from councillor Fraser you have
five minutes in which to address the
committee and I'll see if there's any
questions at the end of it for you thank
you well thank you mr. chairman just
like to point out actually I've been
approached by both the applicant and mr.
Mehra knew from number 42 so I've got to
bring out points from both and I'll
start off with the applicant mrs.
Quinlan who I've met with and discussed
this application
incidentally previously there was a
previous consent granted for a bungalow
on this plot back in 1986 so perhaps
that this previous concern actually sets
a precedent
also Bieber had a previous proposal that
we've heard from the town council
regarding building for substantial
houses on park land behind east house so
perhaps there is a precedent there for
this proposal to go through the
objections raised from a 20-18 refusal
have largely been addressed as stated by
then Alvin the agent that certainly
respect with lowering the height of the
bungalow from one hour a half to a
single story objections have raised by
the management of the leisure center
which is part of the refusal last year
have been mostly resolved and I spoken
with tracy loins the manager there to
confirm this as well the applicant has
negotiated subject to contract rights of
way across the Land Act owned by the
council for access and s we've heard
there is approve the town council has
not raised any objections and supports
this application there's also support
now or rather no objections from Hadley
society Suffolk Oasis and historic
England if consent is granted number 40
will retain the historic garden and
there will be parking for a few cars
there so there has been a precedent set
there is support and issues from the
previous application have been addressed
that said the parking and access those
remain an issue if you could bring up
those slides when to do is just
something else to the vehicle access
will go via the
access to the leisure center and on
numerous occasions there will be service
vehicles sometimes emergency vehicles
parked on that location so as has been
highlighted it is a bio beware situation
with regards to access with the property
for any future owners of that some quite
clear points on this though the apt the
development would be within a
conservation area the is it's a very
lively habitation for our wild birds
actually around that it's quite the life
all around that Park area in the summer
months were to hear the birdsong so
there may be some disruption of that of
course it's in the ground of the greater
listed building and has been this
discussed at length that in the terms of
the NPP F this proposal would cause a
medium a low to medium level of lessons
substantial calm okay
thank you thank you thank you very much
members have you got any questions no
thank you very much I've got a question
for our offices can you elaborate on the
decision for the erection of a detached
bungalow that was granted in 1986 which
canceller phrase refer to and I've now
found it in the papers because you know
you haven't commented on that at all I
couldn't find it because it's 86 I
couldn't find the the plans on the
microfiche for it but and I appreciate
it see if there has previously been a
planning permission on a site usually
going forward that does bear limited
limited wait for some weight
I think because of being in 86 and then
the fact that since then we've had
particularly MPP F with regards to the
Heritage that have actually Aussie honed
in on the fact that any level of harm to
a listed building there's a Native
Heritage a set has to then you know be
outweighed by public benefits but
legislation I can't comment on what you
know what the harm was in 86 or whether
heritage were consulted that it's moved
on considering we've gotta see new
guidance and new and PPF that we have to
follow in terms of the harm to listed
building which is why this application
is being recommended for refusal
compared to the 86 which was also a
grant it's that's why there's the
difference and I think the the previous
outline has a very very limited limited
weight in comparison to what may usually
go forward if there's already been a
that consent granted the fifth doctor
that you wanted to come in but can you
throw any light on this because it it's
it's important that when there's been a
permission granted
and that was a long time ago we need to
know that why it's different and why
would we took one view there and would
take a different view now I think that's
quite important to members yeah Thank
You chair I'm afraid I wasn't even born
so I don't know as Kevin said we
couldn't we couldn't find the records
why certain wasn't here it's a long time
ago and it's a long time ago and as
Kevin said we have an action plan
national planning policy framework but
we also have the planning listed
buildings conservation areas act 1990
and so four years after this development
was supported we have a major act of
white people who came through major Act
protecting listed buildings and
conservation areas and that's that
that's the ad that we still use today
from 1990 and then we've had since then
we've had this splitting off of English
heritage into English Heritage had only
been around two years when that was
approved
nevertheless they've now split off and
they are historic England English
and and they write these things like
this this guidance which is this isn't a
second edition but the guidance is only
eight of ten years old some of this much
more recent and as I said initially
things are tightening up all the time so
something from thirty-three years ago is
going to carry very little weight as
Kathryn said at least from heritage
point of view because guidance and
legislation and case law has moved along
so much since then
thank you I was only briefly going to
agree with what dr. duck had said in the
same way that some planning policies
become more permissive in the last
thirty years we wouldn't then not allow
something because we have refused it 33
years ago I think the same is true here
conservation has become more restrictive
we've seen in repeated appeal decision
the inspectors take this very seriously
so it's gone in the way of conservation
where at least two local plans passed
that date to government's it was 26
years in PBF so although it's a an
interesting part of the narrative of the
site I wouldn't hang too much weight on
the fact that it was previously a
decision for a bungalow 33 years ago
thank you I'm thoughts know was here in
1986 I'm not like this setting on it but
I can't remember that far back
but anyway members were now open for
debate
who'd like to start
pencil about it thank you
I just want to clarify Katherine would
you just explain what you mean by
contrived in this context but I don't
really understand that and it's how it
sat on the plot in comparison to you
particularly for 242 George Street in
there
and forever dwellings within George
Street all set comfortably they have
varying sizes of rare gardens and bit
ends up being contrived in the sense
that it's it segregates a gardener and
it's a small area and then obviously
putting in a new house to fit within a a
small piece of land which is why I've
reached a conclusion obviously it looked
cramped and contrived in terms of you
know the wider area and the appearance
of the orientation I'm the community
space around it thank you
and yes please do I just want to really
it the Heritage aspect really is the
probably the main focus isn't it for me
the assessment of moderate to low home
on the Heritage sort of scale that's
been described and and by the way
they're very good graphics I thought
they were very interactive and really
helped us and I think perhaps if we had
if we're going to expect those as per
norm in the future we might not need so
many site inspections perhaps so really
good and you know probably what what we
do need in terms of sort presentation
but back to this so I really feel
perhaps we are over playing the harm
aspect when we seem to be downplaying
the benefit so of course of course the
harm must be must be assessed in the
same sort of way you couldn't expect to
have a massive benefit because there is
only space for one house but that also
means that the harm is the scale of the
harm is lessened as well yes there's
only benefit of one
house but there's only the harm of one
house so I think we've really got to
make sure that we are assessing it in in
their fair terms of potential harm
so yes it's just a point I wanted to
make I might well come back with some
other comments but could you comment on
that and how you've obsessed that okay
so an SUV like said the public benefits
in a site that's small are always going
to be smaller because you can't fit as
many house in a can't have ten houses
which would then have six being
affordable the problem is that you could
argue and my point is that but but
dwelling could go elsewhere in terms of
a different plot island where there are
no there is no harm to you listed
building and therefore that's that's how
we reach a conclusion that the public
benefit one dwelling that you can easily
put outs where our pre-show sees been
not in the the applicants ownership but
it's the fact that the harm actually
outweighs outweighs for one dwelling
there which could go in in another
location where there is no harm to begin
with
thank you can I just say it the but on
that on that issue the benefit might be
lessened by being elsewhere because the
benefit of that location is that it's
very sustainable there's good
connectivity as I think I've read in the
report to the center of the village and
good connectivity with bus services and
all the other benefits of being in that
location so you might get not get the
same benefits if it wasn't another
location I can see where you coming from
but the npf is very clear there any you
know and it's
any harm and even outside of the
Heritage in terms of a social economic
and environmental strands of a
sustainability concept in the MPP F as
soon as there's harm attributed to even
one of those most wratten's
events you have to our way for public
benefits when it's the listed building
and the conservation area it's it's more
sensitive and the fact that it is in a
sustainable location doesn't outweigh
the harm to be listed building that is
the main main point of it it's the
listed building as opposed to the
location thank you
I've got canceller possibly yeah I think
this is a matter of balance isn't it
hard versus benefit it's I don't see it
as a public but there being any public
benefit there's a there's a personal
benefit further the people who are going
to live in them house the bungalow but
the actual wider public aren't going to
get any benefit from it at all and in
terms of its one house versus another I
mean we're talking about one modern
bungalow versus a unique listed
historically significant building
there's no comparison between the two I
mean I think it it would be we have to
protect our historic buildings they are
a dwindling in number we've got to do
whatever we can to protect them and I
think building in the garden of one a
significant of this would be a terrible
mistake so I can't see any reason to
support it
thank you any other comments councillor
Davis yeah it sort of follows up from
councillor Busby but if you take the
three reasons that the officers have
given full refusal think we you know we
need to support the policies that are in
place and
it's it's been an interesting debate in
terms of is it cramped or is it
contrived you know in the space that's
there but as I've been pointed out it
will take up that pretty much that whole
plot and then I understand the fact that
if something was granted in 1986 but
we've had now 33 years where that listed
building has become even more important
in terms of being a listed building
those policies are there I do understand
the point made about a development as
another house that's built for the
reasons but as as we pointed out is a
personal reason and you know long after
those people move out or whatever yeah
it will still be there this the second
point about the heritage asset well
we've had this debate before many times
and I think the problem lies more in the
way that the heritage assessment is
scaled it's the way it's actually
presented because you know you always
expect it has to be a high-risk or more
than medium risk to be but you know the
way heritage assets do theirs is less
and harm
not unless insignificant so it's the way
it's scaled but you know in my opinion I
agree with the officers on both one and
two points the Third Point yeah I
understand where it says about their
buyer beware but the fact is you know
different a different person might move
in and they may not be quite so
accepting of the area of the amenities
that around in that other area so I
think the lack of any other proposal I
think I propose that we accept the
officers recommendation thank you very
much Spencer Davis do I have a seconder
for that can sort of plan to do is to
comment thank you chair and I would
willingly second that on the same lines
and I'm more than willing to challenge
the heritage
woman's an area that I have some
expertise in but this is totally their
area of expertise and I think we need to
support them by refusing this
application thank you thank you any
other comments or fears ok and cancel
Osborn thank you Miss cheering yes I've
listened with interest to everything
that's been said this morning from
councillor Nick Fraser and the objector
the lady objector there I thought had
some very good reasons for her
objections I agree with councillor Davis
and and but I I find it I've always not
been in favor in the background
development
I think it's harmed quite a lot of areas
although they haven't probably been a
heritage asset within them and I'm
afraid I must support the the officers
recommendation here they've obviously
looked very hard and lengthy at this at
their determination of the policies and
I tend to go along with that thank you
thank you very much Osborn
any other comments the buzzer it's a
question of code point of order ready I
want a court order but at point of
interest on on this buyers beware and I
actually am thought given it much
thought until just started to talk about
it and for instance houses have been
built next to a golf course the golf
course has been there a lot longer but
they are responsible to stop for
stopping the balls going into the the
new house garden and they've had to
spend a lot of money putting fences up
to protect it would they in this
instance would the swimming pool have to
put up spend money to protect the access
to the house
in the future because it creates an
issue a danger of access about it so
there is a buyers beware but there's
also potential cost on existing
operations don't know well mm waiting to
get in so hopefully he'll bear the odds
of that one just I don't know the
I thought you're gonna say something
about noise nuisance sales really for
our boys effort to leap it with with
some advice if there was a noise because
the answer there would be yes they would
be owned with that so I would have to
deal with that liberals in uses to new
householder
in terms of the other stuff I think I'll
part that with the private dispute right
members unless there's anything new I
intend to put forward with the compose
oh so I thought you've done it
sorry chair that's the other point is
you know you could round up I just
wanted to make members just to remind
members of the key paragraph so the
important heritage assets then because
it is easy to run away of not do less
than means something trivially it
doesn't so paragraph 193 of the NPP F
which is page 55 to the NPP F says that
when considering the impact of a
proposed development on the significance
of a designated heritage asset great
weight should be given tss conservation
and it talks in about substantial harm
this is special harm okay we're now
going to 194 and it says any any harm
and harm has been identified by our
experts any harm to the loss of or the
significant Harwich asset even from
development within its setting should
require clear and convincing
justification and then finally 196
reminds us that we're develop proposals
lead to less in substantial harm to an
asset this should be weighed against the
public benefits so you have to seriously
consider what the public benefit is
against the identified harm thank you
right unless anybody's got anything new
I intend to put counselors divers
proposal the accept the officers
recommendation which was seconded by
Councillor plan all those in favor of
refusal please show
those against - that is carried that is
refused
thank you very much comfort break yes
I'll just try and - sorry which one can
I just ask meander the public is
everybody present here for the straw and
run so anybody know so that the sub
three one lots of people here for that
row take that when you come back we'll
have a feedback by eleven o'clock please
you
but I'm very sorry I've lost
and I've lost the chief officer here and
I don't know Wiley I tried to find out
but I don't think that wants to tell me
anything yet so thank you
right so that you know as much as I do
no job and my hands are tied we cannot a
start until I get the legal values are
back and can somebody go and chase up
these offices thank you
welcome back members we're all present
sorry that they went a little bit longer
than we anticipated but we're now on
page 31 and the application is for
Sudbury the 14 born gay shopping
precinct right the case officer is Linda
bacon and we do have Chris Cornish here
if you like to wave to us there we are
and who's the null ears expert for baby
district counsel okay over to you then
Linda to take us for thank you Thank You
chairman this application proposes the
change of use of existing and now vacant
shop unit in the Boram Gate precinct
from a retail use to an eSports gaming
lounge and bar use the applications
referred to committee due to its
controversial nature and the fact that
the council owns our shopping precincts
and that the applicant is related to an
elected member and a district councillor
is an objecting neighbor the site is
shown here hatch red it's located at the
southern end of the precinct which is
this group of buildings here the bus
station is to the south that's the
church there this shows the historic
core of the town center and identifies
the site in relation to the conservation
area and numerous listed buildings this
aerial image gives context to the site
and identifies the precinct here the
precinct bus station and green open
space to the south is the Hamilton Road
quarter which is the subject of a
long-standing proposed mixed-use
redevelopment allocated by the local
plan this is a submitted location plan
the site can be accessed from within the
precinct at this point this point and
from the rear from Great Eastern Road
this is the existing floor plan for the
former retail unit main entrance here
rear entrance onto Great Eastern Road
here the application proposes an eSports
gaming lounge eSports gaming involves
video games and competitions on an
individual or multiplayer basis using
game gaming computers and consoles over
the Internet the proposal proposal also
includes the live streaming of gaming
events a license bar serving hot and
cold drinks and alcohol the playing of
recorded background music the youths
will employ three full-time members and
14 part-time members of staff and the
proposed hours of opening are from 9:00
in the morning through till 3:30 the
following morning and until 6:00 in the
morning on bank holidays a premises
license has also been granted for this
proposal the proposed floor plan here
shows the layout with the bar and
seating area in the lighter colored
shaded area at the top of the picture
and the gaming stations and seating for
the large screen is in a darker shaded
area the main entrance from the
precincts side is here with reception
adjacent and there's a second entrance
at the rear on to Great Eastern Road
Toni's our photos this is the existing
blazed entrance from within the precinct
this is the general view of the precinct
looking towards King's house at the far
end the precinct is partly open to the
elements above this is the left side of
the precinct and shows a an existing
vacant premises this is the right-hand
side of the precinct again including
another vacant premises this is a view
looking sad towards the application site
you can see the glazed
entrance masked out in white on that
building this is a view to the rear
taken from Great Eastern Road the rear
entrance is visible approximately here
as is the three sitting single storey
flats in the darker brickwork located
above this is a view looking towards the
southern end of the precinct taken from
the bus station to the south the
sidewall of the application site is just
visible beyond the red brick building
here currently the precinct is locked at
8:00 p.m. and that's to prevent public
access into the precinct area this is
one of the gated entrances to the
precinct the staircase just beyond the
gated area leads to residential flats
above and this is a view of those flats
above the building at the far end is
this one is directly above the
application site and contains three
residential flats this is a view across
to the other side of the precinct where
flats are also accommodated likewise
this is the rear of Kings house which is
also home to twelve flats this is a
close-up view of the two of the three
flats that's directly above the
application site so turning to the main
issues the main issues as detailed in
the report are the principle of the
development which is acceptable as this
type of use proposed of the type of use
proposed is appropriate in a town center
location and is supported by the
development plan however the specific
details of just how the use will operate
requires careful assessment given the
proposed entertainment news is situated
amongst and below residential property
and that the proposed use is intended to
open until 3:30 a.m.
every night and until 6:00 a.m. on every
bank holiday in this regard vapor
district counselors landowner has
commissions and noise impact assessment
on behalf of the applicant that
assessment concludes that subject is
suitable and verified soundproofing
soundproofing works the installation of
the correct sound system specification
with system controls and together with
restricting customer access through the
precinct after 11:00 at night and the
proper implementation of a noise
management policy and a dispersal policy
the proposed juice will not adversely
affect the residential mmunity of its
neighbors environmental protection
colleagues have reviewed the noise
impact assessment and subject to full
compliance with all of the conditions
listed on page 47 of your report the
application is recommended for approval
thank you thank you just the part i'd
just like to clarify for me slowly 1417
could you clarify the three flats that
are above this premises which I think
used to be called finding two pubs does
that do they go the whole of the length
of the building or are they to the back
of the building or one end
14:17 I made a note
so whilst we're way to meet these flats
are there are 3-3 flats
cover the whole coming fall at the
ground that's what I mean you know thank
you bye
right members we have no Town Council I
think they've got their comments in the
report objector we don't have supporter
we don't have David Debs
you are the agent yeah okay so yeah this
applicant or agent in front of me but
we're all to met so I can't hear you
need to use them the the the flat area
of the residential is 50% of our space
the rest is covered by balcony are our
offices so it's not entirely 100 percent
is about half thank you of that clarify
is it cuz it's BA my memory of that was
that it didn't come all the way right
thank you like you have three minutes so
which to address the committee and that
will start when you depressed about
thank you the premises has been licensed
by the licensing authority with no
objection the police fire and no
resonance objections so it's been issued
by the licensing authority with strict
conditions in relation to planning
there's been none none of three flats
have objected to this application
the main issue that I see is the music
as the main objection but as you saw on
your slides
he's only proposed the background music
the report from the expert is in error
because it says that a bar a sports bar
86 DBA and the Environmental Health
Officer falls into even greater error
because he says between 90 and 100 5db
DBAs required which is actually a that
would be required for a nightclub the
license authority of only licensed it
for an e bar not a vertical drinking
establishment and the plan layer must be
retained so there's no dancing it is
literally alcohols ancillary to the
gaming the gaming is the main feature
there's a completely misunderstanding of
the business model what I would say is
that it's the fabric of the building we
have to take into account the way to
regulate the music is to turn the volume
down how do we control the music volume
well we install a noise limiting device
how do we assess that well we do an
assessment report and normally put that
you can have a condition that says there
should be an assessment report now the
officer recommends that there should be
a validation testing at the end of all
these works that he's proposed a great
expense but why don't you do a
validating test when we just opened and
if the volume is say only 70 DBA you set
the noise limit at 70 DBA and that's it
you don't need to spend all that tens of
thousands of pounds to get the building
back into use at the end of the day we
will be in control of what we want to do
insofar as if the fabric that the
building will only allow 70 DBA you have
at affecting the residents then that's
what we set the noise limiter if we want
to improve the sound we want to increase
it then we have to do works to the
building and spend maybe tens of
thousands of pounds to do that then we
can increase it but ultimately we don't
believe that's required historically
this building has been a super market
lots of noise
lots of activity during the day not one
residence ever complained that this
building can contain background music
without the works that have been
suggested what I would recommend I'm a
licensing expert and a lawyer that deals
with licensing and I've dealt with a
nightclub recently free free 8 the plan
inspector has just said that you have a
noise assessment report a noise limiting
device and the noise limiting advice set
as per the annoys assessment report I
the validation
process which the officer has asked for
after the work is done well why can't
you do it before you don't need to spend
all that money if the volume is set at
the right level it's just turning it
down in relation to people noise we will
manage the rest of your time as I think
you now serve there's any questions for
you cancel our own there's a few points
I'd like to make really because at this
point it's questions to to the speaker
if you've got a question that you want
an answer to the points I think it's
more for debate by all means if you can
put it into a question you can ask him
for his comments with the opening hours
at the moment the precinct shuts at 8
o'clock how how long is the precinct
gonna be open till 4:00 the because at
the moment it shuts at 8 I want to know
how long it's open to if this guy's a
heads the local authority which is the
landlord has said that the preteen
there's no restriction on planning
control regarding the access it's just
each sorry to interrupt out it come back
Kelly turn your mic off so we can thank
you yes sorry as I understand my
instructions are that the land Walter
said there's no control or restriction
on the precinct being opened it's just
normally the fish-and-chip shop would
just close the gates because there's no
other use but obviously if someone's
open wants to be open like the
fish-and-chip shop I asked or anyone
else then obviously the land will allow
the gate to be open it's just making
sure that we can close it and we can
manage it so that it can be controlled
so and we've discussed it through the
licensing and that we will manage the
outside area and we will close the gate
when it's required you can see that the
there are a number of avoid premises
within that building we're putting it a
use back in which is modern that
be managed it is not a bar in so far as
you can see from your office's report
it's so generous it's a gaming center
whether people are concentrating on
games I think you've answered that thank
you up now you've got another question
yeah and what what it is is if there's
antisocial behavior after because it's
only open until 8 o'clock at the moment
ok so if there's antisocial behavior
sort of in the early hours of the
morning if that's when it's gonna be
open who is going to deal with that
antisocial behavior if you're talking
about antisocial behavior of are you
talking of patrons or public in this
it's public because I'm not I'm not
if the worries and the people in the
place itself the worry is the nightclubs
and people coming through I think that
is separate to this if if people are
about there and walking about that's a
police matter does ending social
behavior I don't even blame these people
that was something that may be happening
outside their premises but I can answer
that mr. chairman if you allow me I'll
say well ok we'll close the main gates
and it will be the gates up near the
where the bus error is that we will use
yeah yes so and we will manage that area
to make sure it's only our patrons if if
anyone else is coming in we will ask
them to leave so there's no far affair
thank you
yeah I think I've got your pipe there ok
councillor Osbourne
thank you miss cherry oh my quick
there's two questions really and one of
you partly answered but does that mean
you're gonna have a gate man on that
area where that area is for you to get
into because I I can't you know it's
always been a secure area we have got
quite a lot of anti-social behaviour
going on in Sudbury and those are the
areas that they tend to go for after the
hours after hours yes the the Licensing
Authority considered this too and
they've and there are conditions been
agreed on that alcohol licensed premises
license which means that there will be
stewarded outside and be managed the
other question is in my my time of work
which when I looked at sound levels it
was to do with mostly engines but as far
as I'm aware it was a limit of 85 DB n43
meters so how are you going to actually
say that that area above where people
are going to be sleeping at that time of
the day is not going to be affected
because you know you doors opening
things like that is always it's all a
problem for them well the answer to that
in the report you will see that the
World Health Organization set it as 30
DBA for sleeping in habitable rooms so
that obviously the noise transmission
from downstairs upstairs should be that
after 2300 hours it's 35 during the day
in relation to volume I've said the
easiest solution to that is you turn
down the music and what you do is you
set the music based on a noise
assessment that means that the nearest
sensitive receptor there isn't upstairs
the music is a level that does not
disturb them this is a normal thing with
licensed premises you have a noise
assessment report like suggested by the
officer he says it should be a
validation test but you have a noise
assessment report that tells you what
volumes you can play so you play them
someone's in the nearest sensitive
receptor or out
immediately check the transmission set
the level they may be 60 50 it might be
zero and it might be that they it can't
be plagued but in essence what you do is
you've set a level and then you set the
limiting device that's it
and so that the fabric of the building
will demonstrate what the volume will be
and we'll just turn it down to make sure
the residents are not disturbed so we'll
have to play it at the level fix through
the noise assessment we pull the
validating test thank you just just two
further questions you have a mr. chair
how many how many people are you
expecting to go into that gaming area
during during you know during the days
that you're open well it will depend on
what competitions there are going around
them because obviously they link up
through the computer but we would say
that certainly during the night time we
would anticipate no more than twenty or
thirty people in the building I mean
it's it's not a pub and I don't know if
you know and if you've got anyone that
games try to move your children off of
gaming machines they're on the Machine
they're there to play in the game
they're not there to be drinking at a
bar they're there for gaming so this is
not a late-night bar thank you it was a
reason for asking that mr. German is
that obviously you won't be able to put
a limiter on on the noise that people
make within an area like that I don't
think anyone is suggesting that with
inside the people noise will transmit
it's the music noise in the frequencies
and based the building is in effect as a
commercial building to be designed to
have retail use and then the residential
was built afterwards and that's built to
a building code so the idea of
transition of voice and no one is
suggesting that that is because you
can't limit that even if you couldn't
live me that by putting noise limit ring
but people noise is not the issue here
the issue is music noise thank you and I
think the the other part of the question
that you asked councillor Osborne was
the doorway I
believe there's going to be a lobbyism
there which will help stop this sound
coming out of the building is that
correct at the front if you say that a
lobby is required then you will
condition it with the works but what I'm
saying mr. chairman is that I don't
believe and lobby is required because
it's background music and and if we set
the music that to the level that we want
which is background and that doesn't
break out and cause any nuisance then
then that's the level you say so it's
the noise assessment report so what's
happened is there's an assumption made
by an environmental health and very
expert that this will be a busy sports
bar and will require music of 686 DBA
and we're saying no that's not correct
we're it's much lower than that and I
could just finish this point if I may
that very quick they the doubling of
sound is around about 10 DBA so 76 you
to go to 86 is a doubling of sound it's
not just 10% measure members this is
questions to the speaker but with your
permission if you wanted I'll bring in
the noise expert you might be able to
pick up some of these points and you
might want to continue your questioning
of the speaker are you happy to go along
with that and are you happy to go along
with that thank you I'm gonna bring you
in them because lots of things have been
said and I'm sure you'd like to comment
I think the first part is mr. peds is
repeatedly dismissed any ones wild
assumptions of noise levels internally
looking me Jenny right these aren't wild
assumptions these are based on knowledge
of licensed premises by a noise expert
not just myself but the one that was
employed by the council to assess the
building they're not wild guesses
they're based on typical uses of
licensed premises let's get away from
the idea of bars are the bars it's a
licensed premises so if mr. Beggs
doesn't think 86 DB is the level I want
to go to it could you tell me what level
you would like to go to please
can you just give us a quick answer to
that yes mr. chairman it will be set at
the level that does not disturb the
neighbors upstairs and whatever that
will be that's 30 40 50 that will be the
level set because the objective to us is
that the music must not at the nearest
sensory receptor cause a public nuisance
or a nuisance so therefore we will set
it at the level that the fabric of the
building allows and we believe that that
will be background and will allow us
without doing all that work it's common
sense
turning down the volume I'm not saying
it's a wild guess I'm saying an error
I'm saying this is not a business sports
about the points made where carry on I
think this is the concern really there's
no real thought got into what the
typical volumes they believe they're
gonna committees EEOC's 30 40 I mean
most most living rooms with a family of
four in will be at 50 just sitting there
having a chat and frankly save over your
TV dinners so I don't accept this low
level you can't reduce it to love
anything studies and my experience of
going into bars over the last 20 years
as an unfortunate Officer background
we've just people chatting with no music
can reach midst mid-to-high 70d B's just
people chatting having a good time in a
bar not being unruly or over-aggressive
and shouting is people chained in bars
and restaurants so regards to background
music typically a bar with background
music will be sitting there between 70
and 80 decibels with quiet background
music and you don't need a license for
that you can have an alcohol license
without regulated entertainment after 11
o'clock at night but the applicant chose
to pursue that until 6 o'clock in the
morning is non-standard times so the
applicant is wanting the ability should
they need to in the future and ciliary
to their primary business to have more
than just background music I 86 decibels
is actually a quiet rig light
entertainment so all the yes primary
businesses are they bar that the license
allows them to have regulate the time
what it's a head music at the level of a
disco they could there's nothing
stopping them and their license doing
that and we need to make sort of
buildings capable that typically
somewhere that has a bar a DJ in the
corner a bar in the corner like anywhere
in town what Weaver's tat for example
will be playing music around about 90 to
95 des but it's not allowed this go
mister dad said lacks a nightclub no
like house more like 105 decibels now
well there's quite correct that there is
it's not it's not physically correct
that the doubling of sound is tender so
those that's perceptive human
understanding of how we process noise so
if I asked yourselves to turn your
stereo or double you would the average
person roughly increase it by 10
decibels as measured by an was noise
meter so there is a significant
difference between and it's a
logarithmic scale so I had decibels so
an actual physical real doubling of
sound is free decibels by sound pressure
so we're talking about high level ooh
the higher you go the higher their
impact is so the bubbling of that sound
pressure that's why we can feel noise in
our chest sometimes when you feel bass
going on at 90 DB but he would hear it
at 95 you might feel that we've gotta
make sure in the planning system that
that building is capable containing
noise an expert has been out looks at it
and said it couldn't even contain 86
decibels which is a choir are a quiet
licensed premises it's not a noisy one
it's a quiet one which is of concern
it's an old 1960s retail building in
those days within the head licensees
till 6:00 in the morning about going to
the magistrate's together and in the end
times I would have forced a protective
lobbying so the applicant is dismissing
the expert report and the concerns that
arise six months ago by the Environment
Protection Team at the time of the
original application and the license
application in the building's ability to
contain noise the expert has suggested
conditions suggested works to strap
as detailed in section 6 the reason for
requiring validation is it's entirely
required this is this is creating a room
within a room to isolate the walls from
the existing walls so that noise cannot
vibrate up the structure itself and it
isn't just a flat but it can actually
down on the concrete slabs above so it
could be ones that are on diagonals and
in worst case it could go further
unlikely but could we don't know about
testing so the works are to stop there's
a hidden room if you don't get that
right and don't isolate those works from
the walls you will get transmission into
that structure to put in perspective for
houses they validate ten percent of them
under nhbc rules for normal residential
sound insulation and the building rigs
there is an accepted ten percent failure
rate in that system so yeah that's a lot
how is that every million isn't a
hundred thousand every million it's
accepting that they don't meet the
standard because of what folks in the
workmanship and the inherent problems
with dealing dealing with that and
that's why it's important we get this
right I okay sang with do it once
they're open once the children upstairs
can't sleep and the families upstairs
can't get a nice sleep before work then
we've got issues in every week and so as
the cells the applicant he wants to run
a successful business
so being spots doing what he wants to do
at low noise levels he's going to him to
his business so it's in no one's
interest in my opinion to not get this
right before that business opens I think
we all there understand that so despite
all that you're still your support and
the recommendation for approval but
we've strict conditions I just touched
on people noise as well sorry I just
touched on people no it's increasing
noise from people in our precinct yeah
okay I'm very far yes we've got the
people noise it's this forget acoustic
expertise and and reports picture a
group of people having a cigarette
having a quiet conversation about the
what if they're in the game they're
playing the sport they're watching the
activity they're doing formally is
outside your window at 3 o'clock in the
morning and just ask yourself whether
you think net is something you'd be
quite happy or would you ask them to
move on that's what we're suggesting and
what the app that consisted the
licensing hearing was they would
encourage people to sit on the bench
below the windows about 4 meters from
those windows above to have their
cigarettes now gamers don't want to
leave their gangs but unfortunately
cigarettes are highly addictive and
smokers have to get their fix any of us
would argue against that in fact so and
Windows woman if alcohol was being
consumed we all know that our voices
sometimes get raised and sometimes we
might not talk one after the other we
might talk over each other trying to get
our point talked about the game we've
just been playing or the competition
we've just watched the consultant done a
calculation that's wrong cut it into
numbers so we know from studies and all
sorts of stuff for that that how loud we
are about a group of people to a person
talking is about 70 dB at one meter and
he's done a calculation based on 20
people talking so half a limb people
talking at once in dual conversations
and it was 64 Davis and mr. dad's
wrongly referenced the World Health
Organization because it applies to
general transportation noise and
community noise in the current guidance
from whu-oh it is not an assessment of
nuisance in any way shape or form and
says there in the scope of the document
30-day being a bedroom so the cat the
calculation on 10 people talking will be
64 DB outside those windows above as
shown in the picture in the acoustic
consultants report that will equate to
50 decibels
20 DB above so that one double again
what we H now say the average person can
sleep through that's without the
character the noise someone talking is
more annoying just general traffic noise
which is actually what the WI Chow is
referring say but thank you for that now
I'm going to come to you sir a delay you
some time to comment on some of those
points but stick purely to those points
say it because members haven't had the
opportunity to put their questions to
you yet and mr. chairman that's quite
right if I may say so I don't advised it
but if may I just I mean I know members
of this committee are very well aware of
the difference stream planning and
licensing and some of you sit on
licensing committees anyway but I just
out of I deliberately didn't look at it
before the meeting but have any of my
colleagues got a copy of the premises
license or what I just wanted to note
down it's I yeah thank you very much
thank you I was under license in karate
yeah okay sir you'd like to go and then
after you've spoken
oh then ask the members if they've got
any questions which they might want to
pick up some new two speakers Thank You
mr. chairman in relation to music noise
I deal with that first
the this idea of children not being able
to sleep that emotional language I've
not used that what I've said is that we
will set the noise by a expert a noise
assessment report and if the noise is
that you have to talk quieter that's
what it will be say if we can talk at
this level then that's what it will say
so that the residents will not be
affected and therefore because music is
not our primary business its background
and will we'll set it at the level that
does not affect so there's no danger of
anyone not being able to sleep and if
there was a danger then the
Environmental Protection Act would
prevent it immediately by 1999 by
serving the relevant statutory noise
abatement notice to to cease at
immediately that's not required in in
relation to the 86 DBA that was
mentioned a quiet license bar no your
report says it was 86 based on a busy
sports bar so that that assessment is I
say is wrong I'm not being wild in that
because I'm saying it's wrong this is an
e gaming premises and we are happy to
have a noise limiter setting at their
level that doesn't affect the residents
upstairs because it's background music
and in relation to the what the officer
said about DJ we have to in effect he
says
do the works to to safe-proof you chirp
you proof in case they want to do
because the license allows them to be a
DJ a nightclub well you're asking us to
spend all that money for something that
they're saying that we may want to do in
the future well we're not because you're
granting us planning permission only for
a kneebar if it turns into a nightclub
bit or require planning permission for
that and in any event I'm asking you to
put a condition on the license for a
noise limiting device that sets the
noise limit that we can't change unless
approval by the licensing authorities
aren't the planning authority and very
lastly sir on the people outside I your
officer said 20 people 64 DBA and then
he said ten people 64 DBA and then the
NT is saying 20 people outside all
outside four meters well look what we
say is that we will manage people
outside and it may be only three or four
people we can limit the people outside
or we can move them to the bus station
area but I believe by stewarding
managing the people outside and it can
be limited to five normally because I've
told you out between 12:00 and 2:00 or
3:00 there may be only twenty or thirty
people in there they're not all going to
be simultaneously out smoking we know
the population is about twenty five
percent of smokers that age group is
actually less so the idea of having all
your customers outside simultaneously as
that example given is wrong it can be
managed by the license and it is managed
by the conditions of the license to
promote the licensing objective of
prevention of public nuisance crime
disorder protection and children from
harm Public Safety all that is protected
by the license and that's all been
rehearsed by the licensing authority I
know you there's some overlapping but I
can assure you the music level will just
simply be turned down and said the level
that doesn't affect the neighbors
upstairs that's what we're saying in
principle to use is right it's all about
the volume control we're saying we have
a condition on there for volume control
were said it a level that doesn't fit
the neighbors upstairs
they haven't complained we will do that
responsible that's a proportionate and
appropriate response rather than kidding
it all out just in case this officer
thinks it might turn into a nightclub in
the future thank you right members I'm
gonna come to you now the questions to
the gentlemen okay I'll take penciler
data as well if I can say airs yeah I
think there is a clear distinction
obviously between what has already been
granted through the licensing committee
and I take you understand that and
there's a the father of a teenage son I
totally understand the the concept of
gaming they get the headphones on
they'll chat to each other and that then
that's pretty much it so I accept all
that what concerns me though is a
caffeine lounge you know for coffee and
I'll go away from the license the thing
I don't understand why you need to be
licensed can understand people want to
stay up quite late but I am concerned
about your statement which seems to be
in direct contradiction with what the
environment officer is doing and if we
put planning conditions on here are you
saying that you won't accept those and
you're just going to just not do them
because if we're going to put if we if
we grant this planning permission today
with the recommendations which I think
are entirely appropriate because I think
it's easier to deal with things
beforehand rather than tried to deal
with them in afterwards because then
it's all about question is will you
accept the conditions I think it's a bit
unfair to asked in that bet if you wish
to answer by only to right fine mr.
counselor date Davies obviously it's in
the scope of your authority to make your
decision and if your decision is that it
will be granted subject to those
conditions we can only develop it in
accordance with those conditions so we
have to comply but I think it's only
right that we should be able to equally
say we think that may be
disproportionate because the way you
control is by turning down the volume
you set the volume at that level so so
explain to all that's the bottom line is
yes you could appeal coastal areas you
and me thank you chairman and thank you
for young your descriptions and that is
my ward and I'm very concerned I just
say as a background as one of the town
pastors thanks Larry as your question
you'll get the opportunity to say in
normal debate I'm more concerned about
the fact that it's open all the week and
the control of the youths and you know
if they are there and again the noise
levels that you brought up and about the
smoke and you've said here that you can
move them and if you've got children in
the bedrooms above in the flat when her
people are smoking outside that does
concern me how do you feel you'd cope
with that well firstly in relation to
the first point is that clearly as on a
licensed premises that they'll have to
be after a certain hour adults or with
an adult and we will manage our
customers knowing anyone that's
suggesting that we won't manage the
customers and the license protects
protection to from harm etcetera in
relation to the smoking we believe we
can manage within the precinct the
smoking but if if you don't agree with
us then we will manage them within the
bus station area whether they're not
disturbing a residence what we we
believe that we can manage the smokers
in these premises is he gaming and in
fact most people will want to carry on
with their gaming there that if they are
smoker though that will be relatively
quick there'll be no drinks allowed
outside it will be the smoking and
they'll be going in that there's no
gathering outside we're here do we want
people we in gaming who's next
Khosla Barrett thank you just 100 other
people you're gonna be using are they
gonna be registered as members or is it
you know just just an open open
available to all comers
it can be open to all them newcomers or
people members of public
in time but we expect it to be more
membership late so people will want to
be just in gaming the idea is that
rather than someone being at home in
their bedroom or in their gaming that
they can come together and game together
and it's a much more safer we say a safe
environment we don't we don't expect
general members of the public just
popping in and and starting up gaming it
I think it will be that somewhere where
people will go no different to maybe
snooker but this is a new type of
entertainment that for today thank you
yes so a lot of the concerns about noise
are the late hours really because
obviously that impacts on people's
sleeping and you aren't intending to
open until 3:30 in the morning every
night of the week is there any
consideration of earlier operation time
for perhaps Monday to Friday or Sunday
to Friday the application is that it is
and it's it's been going through the
licensing I know there's a separation
but it's a king to a snooker hall well
that's all I can do maybe draw a
comparison is that the numbers are quite
small our cause you can't be drinking or
be drunk and game is what we say you
can't and people wanting to pay snuke or
whether they gain that's their primary
purpose and the numbers are quite low
and the dispersal is very East not
simultaneous you're chucking everyone
out at the same time it's a gradual
dispersal and we manage and we will
manage that and it may be that during
the week we are not open to those hours
have you got no customers but if we've
got some customers and we want to stay
open then we may but the the license is
there the license and the planning say
in case we want to till
Garlan one more do you operate anywhere
else in the country a similar model know
that there are some examples but this is
a fairly new type of leisure
I mean it's modern I mean I don't do he
gave me I'm him counselor that Davis
thought so that his child my my children
did the same that that's a form of
leisure that aspect they're doing that
rather than going to the pub drinking
it's a different type of entertainment
and leisure type and this type of
building is better - coming to use for
leisure like this and then be vacant and
kill any other questions thank you okay
Cancellara what do you consider you know
shutting the precinct doors a bit early
out rather than until the very early
hours in the morning would that be a
consideration because I think that is
one of the main problems yeah I think I
think it is something that you can
consider I did give it some thought
beforehand normally restaurant if there
was a restaurant in that precinct there
would be a normally a restaurant is to
midnight after that that would can be
consider I think if you were mine d2 and
saying that we have to exit out to the
front and I would say that wouldn't be
unreasonable we believe we can manage it
but if that is concerned I think the 11
o'clock is is too early and particularly
it is a commercial unit that people do
and we haven't had any objections
immediately from the neighbors above and
using their bus station exit we really
we can manage it
and yes I mean obviously you've read
some of the objections and everything
what about the rola door between between
the applicants property and the the
precinct of the job centre you know that
the bars big that's be sorry on page 37
page 37 there's a there's a something
says about a roller door between the
applicants property in the precinct and
the job centre which it would close off
the main part of the precinct and it
only leaves a little bit the area would
that be something you would think of yes
we are proposing to close that off early
I think that will likely to close when
the fish-and-chip shop closes so people
will only use the back area if that's
correct
sorry I let me just double check if I
may
so I think the the one with the
fish-and-chip shop area we've said that
we will close off earlier after the
fish-and-chip shop and we'll leave the
other the other gate or roller area open
so we have access but if you're saying
after 25 to 2300 hours or midnight that
must propose where you have to use the
other door of exit then that's what we
would have to do but we are saying which
whichever door we use we believe we can
do it responsibly through the license
there be a gradual dispersal people will
leave and we don't see that as a an
issue arising an order your colleagues
from licensing thank you there's no more
questions
no you've got that well it's still
questions to the gentleman you've got a
question and cancer Osbourne yeah I'm
just getting back to that topic of
shutting the precinct are you are you
gonna have the second barrier which is
near where you are all right which is
where that is is that gonna be moved up
so you've actually taken that area right
out by having it closed and there on I I
don't believe we are proposing there but
if it's a conditioner which is comes on
to life on to the application and it'll
be a matter for the Latin landlord
wherever they will want to put that in
or whether they see that as I'm viable
because ultimately all these conditions
if it makes it so unviable the it will
be void and there won't be any won't
won't be any commercial activity in this
building it is a proportionate that the
purpose of it is is that the dispersal
people after midnight will be gradual
and we believe we can manage that to not
create a public nuisance yeah
and you mentioned in response to one my
colleagues answer that anybody would be
able to come and use the lounge
and that's great but what steps would
you take to prevent people who just want
to come and have a drink and they're not
actual gamers to come along you know
when the pub's have shot they come to
you so the play of your place because
it's open what can you do to prevent
that happening because I can see it is a
2 to tier you got the genuine gamers
coming in and having fun and and
behaving really responsibly but then
after sort of hours
you mentioned snooker clubs that's
exactly what used to happen there well
in relation to well Snooper clubs used
to have membership and people would go
there for a later drink historically
when the the end of 1964 act because
they were exemptions but in relation to
this the primary business is gaming if
someone wants the coming only for a
drink that's not that's not the customer
we want and we won't encourage that
behavior we won't give service this will
be for good gaming it may be someone is
a gamer comes in and wants to socially
meet someone there and talk about a game
or watch a game because they're actually
watching competitions so that it's that
is driving us we are not a late-night
bar and we have said in the license
there's no vertical drinking so you
can't just come in and just be a
vertical drinking establishment that is
not what we're creating and even though
it's asked for drinking established
establishment under the a for your
officers said no don't do that
use it as too generous for being a gamer
a gaming center because it we are not in
effect a drinking establishment from
that point of view and I actually think
the a1 news covers it as it is it's
debatable whether actually will require
planning permission the question was
what would you do to prevent people that
just come to drink refuse service thank
you right if there's other questions
I've just got one final one for you you
did say the premises being open to the
late hours that am I right in thinking
that if you didn't have the customers in
there after a certain while of giving
the public the opportunity to come in or
members you would then close because
there wouldn't be much point remaining
open if it's obvious that you're not
going to get you more customers day on a
Tuesday these hours are there in case we
want to operate at hours doesn't mean
that we will operate to those hours and
I think and I think that the point is is
that we need we need that flexibility
while we're going for the cost and
expense of making these applications
because it is considerable and there are
some competitions that go later on to
the evening and but maybe I mean so many
times a year so it's not going to be as
described to 3 o'clock every day and
every bank holiday to 6 it will be
driven by customer adulty we don't have
the demand there we will not be open
thank you well this has any new
questions undisclosed should have a
question just mister dad I I used to do
licensing law as well as planning law
right not done much the last two years
so forgive me this does have a indirect
relevance to the planning decision the
committee in making if am I right I've
looked at the license you've got same
alcohol like that refreshment which you
obviously need four cups of coffee after
it between 11 p.m. and 5 a.m. and
regulated entertainment am i right that
gaming playing on gaming machines is not
a I mean obviously gambling's not it's
not gambling I know on vid playing video
games is not a licensable activity it's
not regulation entertainment is it no
it's not it would only be a regulated
entertainment if for example you've got
participation and audience yeah of
gaming or competition so but the from
the licensing perspective I believe that
it's really the license activity is the
alcohol and the hot food and hot drinks
between 11:00 and 5:00 a.m. so and like
those so when when you and when you have
people in the pub watching football or
won't be on TV that's not licensable but
watch of showing films is
selectivity and that is included and in
indoor sports events is included as
presumably for the benefits the doubt -
and you have got recorded music indoors
so I think you mentioned background
music background music normally isn't
seen as a license like tivity is it and
what it is is because as demonstrated in
our discourse today
what is background it's better to apply
for a recorded music but we had told the
licensing authority and they've agreed
on the license and you've seen here that
we will only be doing background music
and how you resolve that very simply is
you have a noise limiter you your noise
officer goes to the flat he goes in
there you put your music up to the level
that you want hopefully that can't be
heard that's the liberal set done just
one one or two additional matters I'm
looking at my colleague over there of
you you made the fair point that
councils have statutory nuisance powers
to deal with excessive noise but this is
it also the case again because I haven't
done much environmental health law since
we were colleagues at any Suffolk years
ago
is it a my unless the laws changed if
you serve a noise abatement notice on a
house it's either a nuisance or it isn't
but with the business is that does the
best practical means defense to apply
yeah it does yes it does but if there's
a statutory nuisance and you've not
taken steps for example if it's I'm
saying we don't need to do that box
within a box all that cost of putting in
effect a
still within that building because we
believe the building as it is will take
background music and if we're wrong on
that then we can't play music or we
can't play it to a volume we we would
require and then would need to do the
works so rather than doing the works and
then realizing you didn't need to do all
that work and spend all that money get
the building back into use as long as
the neighbors are not being affected you
set the noise limiter so III say coming
back to your point is that if we come
along have a noise assessment report
that says it's only 60 DBA
you set it at that and then no-one's
desert there's no nuisance if so I think
that's how you protect it by condition
if we didn't have that condition and we
created a noise at 60 then you can't say
best practical means because we've not
put in the steps that the officers
recommended but I say how you resolve it
is the fabric of the building has not
been tested with music in it it hasn't
been tested with the fixtures furniture
and fittings because it's not fitted out
but once it is fitted out then you do
your assessment with music being played
and you can say well actually can be
played at 60 and 70 no problem without
disturbing the neighbors upstairs that's
the level we set without spending tens
and thousands of pounds on works that
you don't need to do we just thank you
I'm so so she'll notice I think just one
final point if I may I'm the risk of
opening up something but I just feel
obliged to point out I'm following on
from your what we said about playing
video games not being a license of
activity so there is no suggestion at
present that I know your client may not
intend it there's no suggestion of
presence of restriction on hours in the
if the permissions granted as
recommended and other than those that
already exists through the premises
license and so theoretically there may
not be a if the license conditions would
prevent your clients from giving people
an alcoholic drink or a cue a cup of
coffee after certain hours but there is
no
given that as we've just established
video gaming isn't isn't a license of
activity there's no I do I'm not
suggesting your clients have any
intentions on that front but there isn't
that there isn't strictly a restriction
on it that would be easily enforceable
it has a I think the answer no because
it does have opening hours to the public
but if it's a normalized some activities
are unregulated by that license so you'd
put conditions on this planning consent
to mirror the same hours of the license
is that there is some legal doubt again
I've left licensing a lot law behind a
few years ago but there was some legal
doubt about seem to remember mr. Colburn
QC writing about it in journals about
the enforceability of closing times
other than a letter that go beyond the
actual activity Phillip and I have we've
had plenty of discussions on this point
because as I'm a licensing expert the
the enforceability of non licensed
activity is not enforceable by the
license however it is it is said that if
you carry on license for activity that
evening and you don't close in
accordance then those activities that
happening prior have been unauthorized
so if it for example it says you should
have window locks locked
if you don't lock the window locks then
even though you you have that's not a
license of activity locking the window
but you can't have sold the alcohol so
that's the how it is I hope I've
explained that well enough but you'd
need to put the hours on the planning
consent to mirror those of the license
to be sure thank you very much for that
certainly our legal and expert has
understood at all we've tried to follow
it and are happy to accept a question
from our entire glance for any questions
from any bank of your patience thank you
to go yeah it's just
during the license in committee a
question was asked about would people be
able to come in and have a cup of coffee
a alcoholic drink because there is a
lounge area and my understanding was the
answer was yes no I would fully expect
that as a sensational business operator
secondary to the primary business we've
heard a lot about the primary activity
but no she's with that but I would have
success most businesses would allow
you've set up your license
you haven't restricted to members only
to gaming only drinks only be server
gaming you've offered no controls to
ensure that happens in fact I'll be
resisted any controls to ensure that
that's restrictive in that manner so
that's what sorry I think it's just a
question you've got a ste and I think
I've got to be fair to him
was where I was talking about that you
like to answer that to answer that he's
that that the customer described by
councillor Davies is it different there
are different types of customers if you
if someone came in during the day and
wanted a coffee that's non licensable
but if someone came in we winning
together and our children were playing
and we wanted to have a beer and sit
there and then that's permissible
someone coming from the town at two
o'clock when they've kicked out coming
in wanting to have extra know so so I
mean we've been clear in our our vision
on how we want to do the business and as
I say the environment health objection
is is it principally about the music
transfer and being not being a nightclub
we're never going to be a nightclub the
license under the license here makes it
clear that we can't be and a noise
limiting device that sits at say 60 or
70 means you can't be a nightclub
because a nightclub you need about a
hundred 105 DB a thank you all right
thank you I'm going to call it to a
holla fair and less him
member has got a particular question it
hadn't been asked that they want to ask
no well thank you very much mr. dad stop
sitting through that for an extra long
time that is appreciated thankful and
hopefully members have picked up points
now we'll go direct to that the ward
members councillor sue Ayers who's a
member of this planning committee and
it's obviously chosen to stay a member
of the planning committee
so didn't take part in this as normal
but I'll go to you first if you'd like
to start the debate thank you
I just really interested to hear what
other members feel sorry yes but I'll
say one of my main concerns is the fact
that it will be open all the way through
the week and that we do have a problem
with youths and how you know I'm really
worried about how they can ascertain
that the right age group of going in
there and you know everything is being
monitored that really does worry me
Rab interested here what other members
have to say well you have heard the
answers to a lot of those and you have
to decide how much weight you put to
those answers but I think they had been
answered for you councillor Hinton Thank
You mr. chairman we've heard an awful
lot about noise and background music and
all the rest of it but I think human
beings make more noise than anybody else
when it comes to nighttime activities I
think most of us would say that if
you've ever been near a public chucking
out time they're not most of the noise
comes from that the people walking down
the street rather than anything else you
seem to think that they communicate at
maximum volume but I was interested to
see on page 47 of the report that
paragraph 5 he talks about the ancients
doors that are accessed by the bowmen
boram gate precinct should not be used
for access or egress accepting an
emergency between 2300 hours and Oh 8
hundred hours of following day does this
imply that the access to the Borum gate
precinct itself will be closed at 2300
hours rather than as it is at the moment
of 20 hundred hours and therefore the
potential for anti-social activity
within the precinct
is limited in that respect and yes
you're correct there's no need for the
precinct to be opened be honest
2300 hours because we would expect or
customers to enter only fire the rear
door on to Great Eastern Road that that
obviously makes it a lot easier and
especially when it comes to smokers
because it's the noise expert that said
when you get people gathered together
they tend to talk over each other rather
than in sequence so it tends to raise
the level up so with those conditions in
there I'm a little bit happier with it
I'm not quite sure how commercially
viable this is going to be because one
of the problems that we've seen if you
look at the television recently that the
big money competitions are elsewhere in
the world as far as gaming is concerned
and they tend to be fairly raucous
events as well so perhaps we don't want
them happening in Sudbury but it'd be
interesting to see just how one
successful commercially successful look
at the business is and to the impact it
does have on the much volunteer
nighttime economy of Sudbury and how
that impacts upon the availability of
police for the rest of the district well
there will be watching as well as play
and when they anyway any other comments
councillor Barrett
thank you I'm actually quite excited by
this business model which I think is
there is a demand for it because we very
rarely get people writing to say how
much they support an application so I
don't know if they've been encouraged by
being the applicant or whoever and they
obviously know it's
it sounds like that it's just what
they're waiting for
if we can mitigate the the noise then
that seems like a good option and we are
we have to recognize we're in a
transition from a retail model and our
town centers where they you know the the
premises are looking very sad or the
empty premises towards a sort of leisure
and nighttime economy
so I'm I'm concerned that we could deny
you know quite all by doing people who
just want to participate in a what seems
are quite an innocent pastime because of
the activity of possibly some in
anti-social behavior that might happen
but we don't we don't know for sure so I
think it's pretty positive
I am minded to recommend approval
actually so I'd like to put that forward
so you recommend in the offices which
all those conditions there was the extra
condition about the open house yes it to
tie up with a licensing right yeah so
you take that on board to drive with
Elisha's no that's that's fine
do I have a seconder for that all right
can't slow planted you wish to comment
now nope that's fine okay thank you yes
I I think it's actually I think you're
right it is exciting but what concerns
me more is the amount of empty shops
we've got grain Sudbury and there's two
or three in that area so this this would
make I think good use of it there there
obviously trial and new venture
hopefully it will work and hopefully it
would be successful and that they won't
have those problems that we all envision
but and if they do there are enforcement
notices annex that we can impose so you
know I think they're covered so yes
canceler Owen yes I haven't really got
no objections
with it being there the only thing that
I think we've got to make sure we do as
as counselors is to make sure that the
antisocial behavior doesn't happen so
the likes of if they do close at 11:00
then how much of a guarantee do we get
that they'll close in decent doors at
11:00 yes that's what I think we've got
to make this that is make make sure that
is in writing yeah I think you've heard
the comments when you put that to the
applicant and that and there are
conditions governing all that I don't
know what more you want I just want to
make sure that you know when they say
that's gonna happen it happens you know
and and not anyone you know if it says
them gates this shut 11 that they shut
at 11
I would hope that they're going to be
responsible operators and that they will
carry out the conditions as may be
granted to them later on this mornin and
I'll have to take it on trust like we do
with a lot of these things but we do
have powers in the background where we
can use enforcement if they're not and I
think they're well aware of this and if
they're not I think they've got the
message from the members here to tell
you so you know any other comments
councillor is yes I agree is very
exciting and I do hope it is successful
and that it will encourage our
youngsters to do something other than
just go and drink and I just wish them
well thank you that's a good point
councillor I was gone Thank You mr.
chairman and actually I have just one
question to ask of mr. Cornish as a
whole
yeah I'm I'm very much tending to go
towards approval of this ice agree you
know
proposer and seconded however I have
some concerns about the enforcement
Sudbury in terms of what enforcement has
been carried out has been very lacks
over the last few years I'm also very
concerned about the end of social
behavior stuff that is going on and it's
not just antisocial behavior it is drug
taking and that area it has not been
made specifically shut apart from the
area that they need to have out there
I think caused problems and I I'm your
only good I asked I mean I went to a so
a safety conference in in Elms well on
Thursday the police were there I had no
impression that they gave that they are
actually bad could enforce a lot of
stuff so I'll ask mr. Cornish if you get
the problem within with without the
conditions put on here how are you going
to enforce that and how long will it
take because I live in Sudbury I know
what it's like you mentioned that we
were stacked Weaver's tap is have been a
problem for a few years since it's been
going and people in Girling Street
thanks a lot of to individual that I
take your point and I and I do agree
with you but we can't we can't blame
this application for all the other
problems that we may be incurring in
Sudbury but out there certainly there
but they're not responsible for that I
think your point to to the officer was
how could he enforce this particular
application and and we must keep it to
that there are problems around Sudbury
and I'd like to see more enforcement
tape on that like you would but we can't
blame this application for that can you
answer it to ask the question and is we
would have to in into the noise
investigation we will be looking at two
arms that that one would be statutory
nuisance for noise one will be not a
deer into the areas of the license or
license conditions himself to be
brutally honest we haven't gone out of
our
service it would take in the region of
two to three months to gather the
evidence and now it's an allow a notice
period to play out we would have to give
reasonable time under a notice which is
governed by Bayes law to allow works
they're given the extent of the works
that required if if there is direct
sound to have missed it for example then
they've got to strip the whole building
out stop the business and refit the
whole building we've all the cable work
that they are the other state-of-the-art
gaming cables have to come out and go
back in afterwards to get full isolation
so yeah it's not gonna be a quick fix
I'd say best-case if we were lucky and
everything lined up in a row we could
probably deal with it in two months
providing the applicant dealt with the
issue as whoever is in within the
premises here the applicant is just the
first occupier so whoever's in charge
avoid and they are very good and deal
with the issue quickly maybe two months
thank you
did you want to come back on that
quickly before I go to fence today not
that on that specific point but what I
was going to say was that obviously I
acknowledge knowledge what what mr.
Cornish is saying but I would like to
have and I'm not like you miss Jim I'm
not a in favor of lots of conditions on
things however I would like to have
clarification of what conditions are
going to go down on this so that we can
make sure that the enforcement is there
well I'll get the officer to read a
little bit later okay
councillor dave has you've been
patiently waiting yeah um first of all I
think it's been mentioned that the
applicant needs to be applauded for
bringing this idea forward I think it's
an excellent idea as a game Inlet as a
new games lounge yeah
I do have shared concerns with some of
my colleagues regarding the the late
hours and the potential for anti-social
behavior because I can see now I've
lived and worked in inner cities and
I've seen how things can change from you
know 8 o'clock in the morning to 11
o'clock at night and then he leveled
o'clock in the morning till 6 o'clock
the following morning yeah it's a
completely different scene so I hope
everything come too so I would endorse
what councillor Osborne's trying to do
to make sure that we do have the
conditions it was clear from council he
was reluctant to agree with with the the
environment of the set I hope that they
do put everything in place beforehand
because otherwise we've got a hell of a
mess to clear up afterwards
so wallowed supports it the conditions
need to be in place and strong and I
understand about viability as well but
the conditions I think are important
thank you
well I'm going to get mark to have just
three they've what or emphasize the
points that we need to know and make
sure that they're there one additional
condition would be the the barrier
enough of that area of I'd like that in
there the barrier the Burien the the
barriers that are going to be for the
shut of the area that is not just fine
now let's just find out what is there
right and there's no need to add that
I'll see if your proposal seconder will
accept it I'll give the list of the pros
7 conditions did we get some
clarification that proposed a condition
that would be helpful so at the moment
each each condition would have to Clause
2 if you go to page 47 they're all about
we want the details before you start and
then you've got to do it
so condition 1 prior to commencement
development we want details of proposed
works to improve the sound insulation
performance of Windows and main doors
that has to be agreed and has to be in
place before the use commences condition
2 all sound insulation works the walls
ceilings and support pillars is to be
agreed and then if
mented condition three details of the
sound system speakers and speakers
locations to be submitted and adhere to
condition for sound limit limiter to be
installed that will restrict all
amplified sounds to an excess here
eighty six decibels le a queue thank you
condition five which have discussed
already is that the main entrance doors
of de Boram gate shall not be used
unless in case of emergency between 11
p.m. and 8 a.m. and in addition to that
smokers will be directed away from the
precinct condition 6 is the submission
of an acoustic validation report this
will include tests and results of which
confirming the sound insulation is
sufficient for the proposed use and
these details will be submitted to mr.
Cornish and his team for closed
assessment once and if agreed those
matters have to be implemented and the
extra conditions 7 it's quite a long
condition condition 6 will not reveal
all out will be able to conditions 7
relates to opening hours tying those to
the to make it clear the current license
because if the license changes we want
to control by playing so we say the
current license apparently and there was
a proposed condition 8 from councillor
and I just want some clarification on
that was the possible proposed 1 we just
spoke off previous givers but done taken
it in it could be that I'm just not
understanding it properly but gaming
lounge to me suggests to see roulette
but should it be a games because this is
what this meant to be isn't it we have
been referred to as the games so you
know [ __ ] be sure of that you know the
conditional that says gaming yeah we
don't want that word gaming
ok I think that yeah there is obviously
has been a little bit of a discussion
about sorry and also I must I must turn
apologize there are there five there
seem to be five bullet points above
those 7 I've just read out and
going to confirm with the office of
whether those differ from advantageous
Rodell are they in addition to all of
the marine edition - got you okay so the
case so what just what actually
effectively was one massive long
condition but I think for the decision
notice we won't break it down into seven
conditions but above that you've got the
what we've called it a sewer generous
gaming lounge bar from the discussion
we've had a suspect members like change
that to ego ego just to this it's not
casino I think it's probably obvious but
just about the future reference ego
allows yeah we've got the we've got the
standard commitment development which is
three years approved plans and documents
the fourth condition I suspect probably
don't need because a soui generous
anyway so you can't slip for another use
so it's just across that cross out the
restrict use yeah we'll take a for at
the decision notice as well just foot
traffic Asian and then the next point is
implementation of a noise management
policy and dispersal policy which our
colleagues they will have to agree to
and then the next bullet point is
actually the opening gambit for the
stuff below so that's not actually
conditions itself so there we've got one
two three four we've got eleven
conditions therefore and it proposed
post twelve points I think relations to
grow to shut a door or something right
we'd like to take that fight applicants
but Osborn yes please obviously as a
consul to sublet Town Council did
discuss this application and their main
thing apart from noise and the
antisocial side of it
would that antisocial side was connected
with the actual area the main area of
the precinct being closed and only
having the back area would be accessible
after those hours so when that when the
precinct is shut up eight o'clock
sorry it's the it will be the shutter or
the door area that is down that far end
of where the where you go into the bus
park yeah so that needs to be moved up
effectively to shut it you'll be pretty
nude or whatever whatever whatever they
need to do it needs to go further up to
give you that space as locked not the
gaming area or the gaming area do you
wish to add on any this extra condition
well I can just imagine a situation
where the gaming lounge it becomes very
successful and the generates movement of
people more people around the
fish-and-chip shop decided to open in
the evenings I'm a bit conflicted really
but I don't really have a problem with
the barrier being adjusted so it allows
people's fears about the sort of
incursion into the precinct area late at
night so I'll support what the proposal
proposes same group so I just can ask
the case officer if she's got any
thoughts on that and as she knows her
side
and the image here is of the precinct
and for my recollection there's a
barrier at the front here
there's gates here and then there's a
roller just inside here so there are
three entrances into the precinct
so it's council owned property so it's
whatever arrangements are in place at
the moment to ensure three gates are
shut would need to be discussed with
with the council rather than directly
with this application although the the
roller itself could potentially be moved
back at this point somewhere exactly
yeah
so control over the gates is possibly
beyond the scope of this application
members they are in place at the moment
I think we we've got a commitment on the
one to be closed at the side and
encourage people to go at the back I
think we should live with that as it is
personally but I have to ask you do you
wish to take that proposal that Glen
salaat Osbourne's put forward amendment
conditions all right thank you so
members unless you've got any new points
I intend to put this to you all those in
favor of the officers recommendations as
you've heard bid read out please show
that's unanimous thank you very much
there's no one against we've got there
councillor
we were running a little bit late but
we've got one more plan to do but
Stephens bought I think this rotate too
long
like members welcome back councillor
Busby
we do have her member of the public here
for for this item it's on page 13 there
just apologize to those people that said
no patiently waitin to this you didn't
expect the other two to take quite as
long but if you settle for you will see
some of the difficulties we sometimes
head anyway page 13 members and Steven
is taking us through this over to you
and carry on yes thank you very much
chairman and good morning good afternoon
members I will make this as brief as
possible and this is an application
before you today because it exceeds the
threshold for commercial space under the
protocol for delegated powers it's not
considered to be a controversial item
we've received no objections for many
council T there are ting neighbor
representations however that can raise
some concerns but these are felt to be
addressed so the application before you
is a reserved matters application so not
not want you to teach you to suck eggs
but the planning permission for the
principle of this has already been
granted we are now just purely looking
at the scale layout landscaping and
appearance of one of the plots which has
been brought forward by a prospective
occupier and operator so the description
is really as set out in the papers
access appearance landscape and layout
and scale for a warehouse Class B 8 with
an ancillary office accommodation
associated car parking vans storage
cycle parking pedestrian access
landscaping and infrastructure so this
is for the sprawl term Enterprise Park
that see many of the members here will
know and will have visited the site
previously if not I'm sure all of you
fairly familiar with where this is so
this is the old sugar beet site that's
been taken on by if such a bear accounts
all the sea members granted outlined
permission for the comprehensive
regeneration of the entire site a14
running
here you've got commercial developments
around and the den obviously to note
residential dwellings to the south here
beyond the river and and some fairly
dense landscaping along this southern
boundary and then some more dwellings
from sportin I think that's getting away
to the west it's just a constraints map
shows obviously flood zones to the south
contaminated land obviously because of
the the historic past use of the sites
but that's has been dealt with by
conditions on the outline and there's no
issues in that respect that's just an
aerial to showing the siting context so
the application site itself is shown
here obviously members will recall and
I'll show you some aerial perspective
shortly that they permitted a another
distribution facility to the west here
for LDH Liguria which is obviously well
underway I think the shell is is up and
there now on the internal fit-out and
context this plan forgive the flashing I
think Vincent put this slide in for me
the this is development areas plan which
shows that following the outline
permission the science has effectively
been broken up into plots which is where
you would expect to see built
development coming forward see where
we're now talking about that flashing
area here this blue diagonal line area
here is where the LDH la Doria site is
and was permitted and is being
constructed we also at the moment have
another application in for some
infrastructure which would be an
attenuation Basin and landscaping here
and then the roadways to effectively
serve this new developments
this is a site plan showing obviously
the building here car parking to the
east or van parking rather because a
distribution facility employee parking
to the front loading bays at the rear
these are sealed docks to minimize sound
leakage and then we've got waiting areas
here and there's a plan in a second
which will show you some of the
circulation routes velocity the county
councillors Highway Authority of raising
an objection this is then just an
assumed insight plan effectively of the
building itself and some elevations see
if a genuinely unimposing development of
this scale is one of the matters that
members here to consider today and
obviously the site wide outline
permission sets a parameter for a
maximum height of 28 meters this
building is only thirteen point three
five meters so relatively unobtrusive
and obviously would now be read in
context with a big load OREA building
adjacent to the west and so you've got a
lot of glazing to the front there as it
meets sort of the frontage of the site
and the more active areas of the
enterprise park and the views from the
rear and then side elevations though you
can just about see then these are the
HTV docking bays site sections very much
similar to what you've just seen
obviously generally flat sites and the
members that did visit the site
previously when we dealt with the
outline application will recall that
there are differences in levels between
this site and then the residential
dwellings to the south obviously
separated by the significant landscaping
along that southern boundary and the the
river at the river and it's a footpath
and some illustrative sections which
just really show some of the landscaping
at the front of the site there which
I'll come on to another
man in a second this just shows that
there are four points of access all the
developments obviously this is all
internal within the enterprise park
these have been considered by the
highway authority as acceptable there is
a plan in a moment to believe which will
show the circulation how that would work
but effectively you've got four accesses
to ensure that there isn't conflict
between employees and delivery vehicles
and HGV going in and out of the site and
here is one of those plans so you can
see here where you've got I think the
blue blue area here you've got employees
coming in and then effectively you've
got the circulation routes which then
splits bands from HGV it all looks
rather convoluted but it is logical and
coherent in the sense that as I said
previously it's two to minimize any
conflict between users not standing at
all that's obviously an operational
matter for the the applicant themselves
and then in the evening obviously seeing
a drop-off in circulation there and this
is a landscaping plan obviously
landscaping is more of a significant
matter within the wider site with the
outline permission obviously we've got
past was here being developed by Ipswich
Borough Council where they are carrying
out or intending to carry out the
attenuation Basin works suds and
landscaping and other areas around the
sites There is obviously some plot
landscaping here we've got some
landscaping to the front and then around
the sides and then along the rear as
well there is soft landscaping but also
a three point four meter high acoustic
fence I'm off see we've just done noise
to death but the Environment Protection
officer was satisfied that this will
effectively mitigate any potential for
adverse impacts to those neighboring
residents who are more than 160 metres
away to the south and actually there's
not there's another benefit with this
fence as well because it's close
bordered acoustic fencing it will also
contain all of the headlights from any
of the vehicles coming into the site so
and we're of one of the two where
presentations that we received and there
was a concern about light spill from
headlights that's effectively now
contained likewise with noise and here
are some aerial perspectives so we can
see here looking across from the West
and you've got the Liguria building the
site here which has been outlined in red
roughly speaking and obviously that very
dense kind of tree cover there to the
south and the residential properties and
more properties there it's broughton
across the da14 and this is a view from
the north so again you can see that the
Doria building there with this siting
context and obviously then the rest of
the enterprise park to the east and
obviously important to pick up that
there is obviously more commercial
development to the north and the east as
well of the site and then from the south
just so you can see another perspective
there of the residential properties on
collin Sion's coming off happily way
Hadley Road the river here and there the
river footpath and then the the site
here in the middle and the SyFy to
effect to be looking in to the site and
where one of the access points would be
looking across to the south there and
obviously again that that heavy
landscape southern boundary so members I
think as I said at the start
officers considered to be this a fairly
young controversial item it is here
purely because of the amount of floor
space the outline planning permission
has already set the principle of
developments ie that this is acceptable
subject to meeting certain parameters
for example height floor space and where
the development itself would go this
complies with all of them someone that
basis members recommendations for
approval subject to conditions thank you
very much for that we have a public
speaking we don't have
ten canceled objective supporter but we
have the applicant or the agent mr.
Derry
I'd like to come forward I'm s-sorry we
have three minutes in which to address
the committee at the end of a pressure
to remain seated or standard and I'll
sit as any questions for you thank you
good afternoon members and chair thank
you for your time this this morning and
this afternoon and I'm not proposing to
speak for the full three minutes
believe your officer has outlined
everything you need to know about the
application and the applicant is is keen
to contribute to this redevelopment
scheme which is long been an objective
of the local authority to redevelop this
site bring it back into active use and
generate a significant number of jobs
for the area so I'm just here to respond
to any questions you may have
following that description thank you
thank you very much I guess Livington
thank you thank you for your patience
and waiting for us to get to this point
just a just a quick one not really a
planning matter but to two aspects to it
one how many are likely to be employed
on the site and two what does it
actually do in terms of distribution and
just to give a description of the
proposed use this is part of an ongoing
logistics operation it represents the
last mile delivery phase so it's parcel
deliveries coming in from larger salt
centres that are coming in for that
final transfer to the Devon delivery
stage that would go to houses and
deliver those parcels in terms of job
generation we're looking at
approximately 500 direct and indirect
jobs that would be split between the
warehouse up
and the van drivers so the principle
jobs that would be associated with the
site would be the van drivers coming in
and delivering those parcels to the
local area thank you thank you very much
indeed that's encouraging was chairman
to see jobs being created in the area
rather than just moved from somewhere
else which is what unfortunately what's
happening with Liguria which of course
is focusing all of their various
operations into one spot so it's
actually just moving jobs around rather
than created and this seems to be
creating them and it's also nice to see
that it's not another fast food outlet
which is what it used to get the famous
four will stick to this application yes
any other questions Oh councillor
Barrett thank you might have missed it
but were we given hours of operation for
the the site we haven't set the hours of
operation because those were kind of
part of the outline parameters and the
operation would principally be for Age
TVs would be coming in during evening
hours to deliver the parcels and then
van drivers would be picking those
Valley you've got vans coming in and out
all day it's sort of one outgoing
contingent and then coming in once
they've finished their deliveries so the
daytime hours hence labert I've got the
officer who can help we only really to
underline what the applicants agent has
said that you know this is a 24-hour
operation effectively in terms of how it
works which is not unexpected for its
type and also bearing in mind the
context of that wider Enterprise Park
the environmental protection officer has
suggested conditions in respect of noise
which include for example management
strategies for minimising reversing
peepers things like that and then also
the acoustic fence which um perhaps
unlike the previous applicant this
applicant is more than happy to take on
board and wants to ensure that they're a
good neighbor
- - surrounding developments just
picking up on the jobs point as well and
something else there is that the
applicant is very keen to work closely
with our economic development team and
have agreed that we will impose a
condition requiring a strategy for local
procurement and also upskilling of jobs
as well so effectively a unemployment
and Skills strategy plan which i think
is really quite positive thank you I
think that I've just revised you will
stick to this application thank you
yes it's the batter and would it be too
far to get to ask whether they are
contracted hours or casual mixture I
believe it's it's a it's a mixture of
skills but I think mainly skilled
operation I mean the van driving is it's
you know drivers so it's open to all
sort of ports of life but there would be
a variety of jobs available I'm not
talking about skill I'm talking about
whether they've got security of
employment on them is this a really a
plan on point but I'm sure you could put
your name down if you're really
concerned to cancel apparently any other
questions no yes we got one girl them
sorry
has any thought being given to the
well-being of the employee that's
working in this environment which is
windowless as far as I can see a belief
there is fenestration with E with the
offices the office part of it and then
there is a whole program of employee
welfare's and benefits and terms of
taking care of staff and that's all part
of the companies and you know wider
operation thank have a little advance if
there's any other questions
No thank you very much thank you
right we won't come to the board board
members Chancellor our data and
councillor Norman naive omnipresent so
members over to you all right
John I'm sorry case Kessler Hinton I'm
quite prepared as a gem to recommend the
officers approval
do I have a sector case of data yep
nothing to add no right all those I
thought you said no chance the Busbee
but I mistaken
do you wish to inquire this upskilling
of these vampires were they becoming
Formula One drivers no I'm not gonna lay
that one okay
it's been proposed and standard that we
accept the officers recommendation all
those in favor please show anyone
against to come on just once
so that's carries thank you very much
well members have actually got to the
end of the agenda the next meeting is
scheduled for wednesday the 20 of the
november and at this moment it's still
upon okay thank you very much but I
think we've got so there's a bell coming
to talk to us on a briefing
I have a meeting closed thank you very
much we see a counselor who you ask